right thank you very much welcome to
tonight's planning East committee my
name is Andy km and I will be chairing
tonight's meeting um the purpose of the
meeting is to judge the planning Merit
of the applications in front of us um if
I could crave the bearance forbearance
of the audience could you make sure your
phones are either on silent or turned
off because there's nothing worse than
being interrupted by the tunes The Great
Escape
ory can V I've got yours yeah you made
that way um and also please could you
not shout out or interrupt the speaker
the registered speakers however tempting
it may be and I'm sure sure I can
sympathize on some occasions that you
might be wanted to shout out but please
do not shout out please thank you um
just like to introduce the top
table Olivia quen committee Services M
nice Legal
Services uh my name is Richard Gardner
I'll be the planning manager for the
first item uh in my role as an impartial
advisor to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise doing so
I'm Bound by the code of professional
conduct of the royal town planning
Institute
planning committee members not bound by
the case officer's recommendation or by
Oral
advice Tony Horton senior
planner Karen Tate I'll be managing the
items other than item
one I'm team needer plan is East in my
role as an impartial adviser to the
committee I can clarify any planning
issues that arise doing so I'm Bound by
the code of professional conduct of the
royal toown plan planning Institute
planning committee members are not bound
by the case officer's recommendation or
by Oral advice thank
you right thank you very much move to
the First on item on the agenda which is
apologies for absence chair apologies
from councelor brain and councelor
Kendall um item two disclosure of
interest of counc Fielding councilor
party I've had a letter with regards to
the first item 18 stroke
03307 RM and I'm openminded about the uh
thing today counc par then councelor s
chair I've received similar
information uh Mr chairman I've received
information by email but I thought it
was for the second application
the land adjacent to verie road light on
Heath so I'll reserve my judgment on
that but that's where it
was so you are Comm into to committee
with an open mind everyone absolutely
open mind thank you can you just confirm
they the same EMA yeah and just for the
record can we confirm everybody has di
the email letter from from that person
for
the yes I've had one from the e
application I thought it was the first
one yeah it is yeah it is the first one
yeah thank you right moving swiftly on
we move on to item number three on the
agenda which is application number 18
03307 RM land west of the
b4100 Bamber road light on Heath Reserve
matters pursuant to eight line consent
50976 relating to phase one for
development of of 140 dings Landscaping
Associated infrastructure including
roads electricity substation sewers gas
govern the compound Farm water pumping
station attenuation ponds pedestrians
cycle routes and access point through to
ecology reserves eight loan application
was an eia development and an
environmental statement was
submitted so I will now move on to T
presenting this one and I'll rest my
voice through it thank you thank you ch
this is the committee context site so I
will have some more context um slides
and some context aial photos so uh don't
be too perturbed if you haven't quite
worked out where we are but this is just
North of the Lorn Heath Village it's
part of the The Wider GH allocation
there a bful 100 running past the site
there's an Old Quarry to the west and
you got the M40 which runs off further
to the east uh and chesteron WS further
to the North and then in the context
wider strategic context the the fossway
running uh north of the site as
well this is a slide of the G core
strategy allocation plan so this shows
the site which is here edged in red the
bway home site uh you see it's a part of
a a much wider allocation in the core
strategy for 3,000 dwellings which will
be on the Imp land to the north the ceg
land to the south of that between that
is a new Village Center over the road is
the bellway site which is also allocated
as part of the residential allocation to
the west of that me stands for managed
Ecological
Reserve south of that there's a small
parcel of blue land there which is
employment land for Aston Martin lagond
and if you go back over the b400 the
other side side of the of the existing
jlr um complex there's 100 hectares of
employment land for jlr which runs all
the way down to Junction 12 of the
M40 so that's the whole of the
allocation site to say 100 hectares of
employment land 3,000 dwellings a new
Village Center and before you this
evening is the bellway homes um Reserve
matters which is the 140 dwellings
the application sight edged red the
reason for showing this is you'll see
there's a a small part of the site which
is edged blue down at the bottom let me
just uh zoom in on that
aspect and that's just north of existing
dwellings which are on Stonebridge Road
and Commander close that's deliberately
been taken out of the reserve matters
application site uh for bway RC to gift
that land to the owners of these
properties on commanders close as part
of their Mitigation Of of any impacts I
I will come back to this matter uh a bit
later so to the
uh west west of the site there's the
managed Ecological Reserve we've got the
light on on Heath residence existing and
on the other side of the road will be
the new Village Center and the uh The
Wider parts of
glh so aerial view so to orientate
yourself you've got the M40 in the
foreground here we've got I am
properties development which is a
separate outline uh application for a
thousand dwellings we've then got the
main part of the CG bird controlled land
we got the area for the new Village New
Center Village and then we got the
bellway land on the opposite side of the
road and then behind behind that the Old
Quarry and then the start of Lorn
Village Lorn Heath Village sorry and
behind that Aston Martin lagond and the
jlr complex and then further in the
distance the employment
land uh another aerial view with context
so once again iron properties in the
foreground bway homes parcel on the
other side of the B4 100 opposite the
new Village Center and then the the
remainder of the residential ings uh for
the CG bird controlled
land and then another aerial shot so
this shows the extent of the Old Quarry
which will become the managed Ecological
Reserve and uh at the back of that
there's an area for sports pitches
relating to the ceg part of the site and
then we've got the bway homes Reserve
matter site this evening and then behind
that we've got the uh the context of the
uh Lorn Heath
Village
this is a
composite uh plan of illustrative layout
for both the
C uh bird parts of the site and the iron
properties part of the site and then we
see the bellway homes parcel here in the
context of that so strategically it's in
quite a very sustainable uh location
because you've got on your doorstep the
light on Heath existing Village and the
facilities that has you've got directly
opposite the new Village Center as will
be you've got the CG uh Birdland with
its Associated um Open
Spaces just further to the north you've
got the IR properties uh uh proposals
with their large area of open space and
if you go west you'll have the managed
Ecological Reserve which will have
access Arrangements through that and
then just south of that in this area is
the area for the sports pitches that are
being
proposed as part of the outline
permission uh a number of par parameter
plans were uh given permission as well
and these set out the parameters of how
the reserve matters will come forward
this is the land use uh parameter plan
which shows the bway site here in yellow
and that denotes that it's got
residential development use so the
principle of residential use on here has
been accepted by the outline permission
that was
granted turning to the access
Arrangements I just zoom in on this
so so these are the technical access
drawings so that the access comes
directly onto the b4100 there a series
technical notes here but this shows the
the various visibility spays there's a a
right um hand ghost turn Junction here
and then further to the South down here
will be the start of the crossing points
which will feed into the uh The Village
Center I'll also show you the adjacent
slide which is a footway cycle way which
runs from the AIS all the way down to uh
Lon Heath Village and you see there are
a series of links through to gford Road
here so this will be for pedestrians and
cyclists to get to the various uh
facilities that Lor uh Heath Village has
such as the school The Village Hall the
shop and the play facilities and sports
facilities uh and that um will have to
be uh put into the scheme prior to any
occupation of the bellway site there
wider b400 improvements as well which
will come through as the uh the glh
development gets uh uh brought through
and
delivered moving on to the hierarchy
plan so this shows the hierarchy of the
roots through the site so the brown is
the primary route running through the
center of the site the the spine Road
it's been called The Avenue at this
stage and that will link through to the
back of the site thereafter will allow
access through to the sports facilities
and sports Pavilion which will come on
stream later in the developments of
glh um we also have these green Roots
which are secondary roots and blue Roots
which are tertiary roots and then the
hierarchy is finished by the yellow
Roots which are the private drives
you'll also note these slightly darker
hatched areas here those are part of the
traffic calming proposals
the site is uh designed for a 20 mph
speed limit and so a series of design
measures are incorporated into this such
as bends in the
road we've got this darker hatched area
which are raised tables so they will
slow speeds as you're approaching the
various Junctions through the site we've
also got uh a series of interventions
where there are longer straight uh
sections
so here you will have uh let me just
zoom in on
that section here you have a series of
um n Road
narrowings uh which affords planting in
that case which will slow the uh the
traffic down in those circumstances so a
series of design measures to ensure that
traffic speeds are low ideally to the 20
mph speed we've also got this red route
at the bottom here which is the uh
footway Cycle Way which will connect
through to the uh the link to the sports
facilities and the managed Ecological
Reserve at the the back of the site and
it will link through to the beef4 100 as
I mentioned before we've got the footway
cycle way which runs the length of the
b4100 and well that will also link into
the crossing points for the new Village
Center
opposite in terms of the layer
um if I just zoom
in that's the chair of the council by
the way and you would here when I turn
the phones off so sorry about that okay
so so we have a a layout that follows
good design principles of um perimeter
blocks of dwellings and a generally
relationship of backto back with um with
Gardens we have the the road hierarchy
as I pointed out and the um the footway
cycle way which links through and we'll
link into the the site there are also
possibilities for further links um to
the footway cycleway as it runs along
the
b4100 you'll see that I've put um a
series of a selection of some of the
house types um on on the site there was
been quite a lot of discussion about the
the style of houses that there should be
uh for this parcel of land there was a
design review panel set up which advised
on that and there's also
discussions um with the parish council
following the preapplication stage where
there was quite an adverse reaction to
uh to the site being completely
contempary house um styles so we've
ended up with a blend of house styles
depending on on the context of the uh
the site so for the northern section up
here around the perimeter of the uh the
edge of the managed Ecological Reserve
the park Edge and for the area which
adjoins the existing light on Heath
Village those will be uh traditional or
arts and craft style uh houses so these
houses on the left side um with a range
of materials uh including uh stone brick
uh some render
elements um in the area uh which is to
the fronting onto the b4100 and along
the first stretch of the uh the main
spine Road there's a more contemporary
approach style it's fairly mild
contemporary approach but it's that
leads it to the context of what will be
over the road which will be the new
Village Center so these houses you see
on the right of the the slide are the
house types which Echo those on the
other side of the traditional but these
have got the uh the slightly
contemporary twist to them um in terms
of their
approach um as I say the there's a
gradation of styles from traditional
through to the Contemporary at the uh at
the this part of the
site uh see the Street Scenes which I
will zoom in
on these give you a FL fav of some of
the uh the streets so part of the Avenue
at the top uh part of the primary
streets so that's got the the start of
the Avenue that's got more of a
contemporary feel to it uh secondary
Street uh beneath that through part of
the scheme got another part of the
secondary Street this is more
traditional end to it you see
incorporation of chimneys and design
features more tradition
styles of
detailing uh along here we've got the
fronting the be 100 the southern section
so this was the section that will be
opposite the new Village so we've got
the more contemporary approach to those
um dwellings there and then underneath
that the northern section fronting the
beef 100 so that section as you first
approach um kind of the gateway to the
bellway site you've got a traditional
large scale house hous is fronting that
to create that importance to the which
is the the key route through the the
Hall of glh which is the
b00 um some of the key matters which I'm
sure committee will be faced with this
evening relate to impacts on the the
residents along the south of the site
here um there's two key elements to that
one is a direct relationship between um
the properties on the southern boundary
and those existing and the sighting of
an apartment block so I've got the
elevations of the apartment block that's
gone through uh various design
iterations to improve on that so it's
been broken up in its scale and massing
it's broken up by the the ridg line
changes and use of different materials
and uh to Officer's opinion that's now
resulted in an attractive and
well-designed building um in terms of
its location which has proven to be
something of a an issue with the local
residents and the parish council um at
the pre-application stage it was in this
corner of the site here uh and there was
quite a a backlash to that certainly
from the residents of uh Stony Road
along here so uh when they get to the
application stage bway homes decided to
move that to a location on the edge of
the site adjacent to the uh the park
Edge in the managed Ecological
Reserve now officers felt that um that
had uh quite significant implications
for the character um and impacts on the
the the sensitive Park Edge there uh we
had been happy with the uh the location
in the first instance subjects are
getting appropriate distances but we
were less happy with the location there
so a third location has resulted and
which is before members this evening
which is in the location here so if I
just zoom in on that part um just to say
this is a superseded layout we're
currently looking at um because I wanted
to to show where the three different
locations had been previously so this is
the current site for the
apartments um it's over 60 M away from
any Residential Properties on uh
Commander close here and there is
intervening planting here and it is
orientated not to look directly at those
um those existing dwellings as well it
also affords surveillance of the footway
cycle way which will run past there so
um in design ter terms it's uh found
acceptable and supported by officers in
that location and that that
design um the
other key issue which no doubt will be
uh touched on this evening are the
implications for residents at
Stonebridge
Road properties here and properties on
commanders close it's quite an unusual
relationship of these dwellings on
commanders close they're actually
granted on appeal um at the back end of
the '90s early 2000s after being refused
by The Authority but they did result in
these two dwellings right on the
boundary of the uh the that development
site command is Clos and right
overlooking what is effectively the uh
the field which is the bway site um with
little very little breathing
space um as part of this process um that
bway have gone through with officers and
listening to the parish council and
Neighbors uh they attempted to find ways
at appe appeasing the neighbors and
making various design changes to the
scheme to improve on that
relationship so I'll just run through
some of the um the matters that have
been uh carried out through various
iterations of the scheme and we are on
currently revision s of the layouts and
we started at a so there have been quite
a few changes and amendments going
through the
process um first off is that the
distance that officers require between
dwellings um habitable Windows is 21 M
and so the scheme has been designed to
achieve 21 M between Windows and in many
cases we've got far in excess of that
for example we're looking at uh well
over 30 m in that kind of
location uh secondly BW changed the
scheme to provide gaps between the
dwellings here so there's some breathing
space that you can see for these
existing commanders close residents to
be able to get some uh views through and
there's a much larger Gap here between
dwellings as
well thirdly the dwelling here has been
off deliberately offset so it's not
directly opposite three commanders close
or four it's between the two so you've
got that uh slight off
setting U number four the dwelling have
uh I've only got one Upper Floor window
I think if we can assume that ground
floor windows will be screened to a much
larger extent it's really the first
floor Windows where the issues of
privacy overlooking are of key so those
properties only have one bedroom
window um another issue which was um uh
raised by the residents here was the
number of affordable units in this
southern boundary location and the
affordable units denoted by these dots
on the the units there were uh two
affordable units in the center here and
bway have decided to relocate those to
another part of the site so effectively
we've got some affordable here a long
run of private houses and then
affordable in that location
there uh further thing that bway have um
said they will do is this land here
which I alluded to before as been
outside the application site BW have
said that they will gift that land to
the residents at three and four
commanders close so they will
effectively uh be gifted a new um rear
Garden which by my rough calculations
would double the size of their Garden it
would create that um breathing space
between their house and the backs of the
new houses which would as I said before
provide that normal relationship of 21 M
that you get uh between
dwellings um the other elements that
have been looked at are boundary uh
fencing being put in um along here and
between the um development and the
gifted land that's the currently 1.8
meter high boarded fence there and also
there were concerns about uh the parking
space you here shining lights into the
the rear of the properties here so an
evergreen Laurel hedge has been proposed
along here with a fence to the rear of
that to while that's growing up that can
provide that um that assistance and
preventing the light spread uh and also
Landscaping elements have been
introduced so the close boarded fence
along here has got Climbers on the the
Stonebridge road side of it to to soften
the impact of that got the Laurel Hedge
and we've got a series of tree and shrub
planting which will further filter views
and uh help that relationship uh to
mature over time um I also understand
that bway have written to the the
neighbors of Stonebridge and commanders
close um and offering um assistance in
helping choose the planting uh um along
there um that's not to say that all the
requests of the the residents have been
agreed to but in planning terms the
scheme achieves appropriate distances
boundary treatments planting and
building relationships for it to be
acceptable in officers uh in officers
view chairman the um the key update uh
really on the update sheet is that the
highway Authority have now received
sufficient uh Amendment and additional
information for them to remove their um
concerns and they now raise no objection
so as a result of that the recommend
ation is no longer subject to the final
comments of the highway Authority being
received but can instead be a
recommendation of approve subject to
conditions thank you
chairman thank you for that very clear
and concise and comprehensive
presentation uh before we move on to our
first Speaker councel oon I believe you
need to raise Point Ben cast um I do
apologize um chair but I've just
realized there could be perceived
conflict of interest so for transparency
I think it's best if I sit the rest of
the um presentation
out ccor
Saint yes chairman the um risk of making
myself look a bit of an
idiot um I'd like to clarify the
representation I received it was on this
application and not the next one and it
was from Lorraine and John edcom which I
presume is what everybody else can with
so that's what I've had I thought i'
better clarify that before we went any
further that's great thank you cancor
Saint well now move on to our first
Speaker which is councelor Maggie
Heder are you
here thank you I didn't think you here
for a minute I
was you uh have 3 minutes councelor
Heder would you like a warning with
about 30 seconds go pleas
okay press press the button in the
middle
button good to
go there has been significant engagement
between bway the district council the
parish council and residence in
Commander's Place in Stone Bridge Road
which has resulted in changes to the
design and layout of the initial plan
however the parish council maintains
this objection to the reserve matters
application for the following reasons
this site was brought forward as phase
one in the outline planning application
however without the infrastructure and
Facilities associated with the original
phase one development we are concerned
that this proposal will become no more
than a standalone large scale housing
estate alongside Lor Heath as there is
no agreed time scale for The Wider
development the lack of of improvement
works on the b4100 is of serious concern
concern particularly as it does not
Accord with the supplementary planning
document relating to the original phase
one site and I quote by commencing
development at this location
intervention on the b4100 could be
introduced to benefit existing residents
under this proposal residents in the new
development wishing to use facilities in
light on Heath will have to walk along
the pavement adjacent to fast moving
traffic on the beach
4100 the introduction of the proposed
140 houses without the b4100 mitigation
Works will only add to the current
travel delays caused by heavy traffic at
jlr AML rush hour or Motorway incidents
the parish council strongly object to
the inclusion of a three-story apartment
block which is contrary to the
supplementary planning document which
strictly limits the scale on this site
to two stories successful discussions
took place with local residents the
parish council the district Bel and
Council on bway to relocate the
apartments away from the northern edge
of Lor Heath however subsequent revised
plans show the apartment block now the
highest elevation of the application
site
and and alongside the northern edge of L
on Heath this retrograde step is
extremely disappointing for local
residents and the parish council who
feel that their views have been
disregarded resulting in a reduced level
of trust that has been established with
key stakeholders it is disappointing
that the affordable houses are not
worldwidely distributed across the
application site rather than being
mostly clustered around existing
properties in commanders Clos in
Stonebridge Road the replacement of the
originally proposed semi- detached
properties with Terraces of three have
resulted in the need to provide RAR
gated access to the middle dwelling this
is a security 30 seconds for residents
in commanders close and Stonebridge road
while steps have been taken to mitigate
this impact it will be far more
acceptable for the semi detached
properties to be reinstated in
accordance with the SPD vision of the
par character Edge Mel and Heath Parish
Council requests the committee consider
these points when reaching a
decision thank you very much that was
almost spot on well done you want to
take a deep breath now so just to get
your thoughts back in order uh any
questions for the council barns
please I along today um there isn't a
there isn't a Crossing or do you not
need a cross in from where you
are there there isn't a Crossing on the
b4100 with the um proposal of the
mitigation Works traffic would be calmed
and there would be Crossing points that
isn't part of this bellway development
and we feel that this poses a
significant impact for particularly
people want to use it as a pedestrian
access into the village
um it is a concern to us that they will
have to walk along the side of the road
with fast moving traffic and anyone
who's experienced rush hour in that area
will know that that's not insignificant
we're going quick enough this afternoon
okay
thank thank you chair good evening um
you raised your queries about the um
traffic mitigations and you've also
mentioned the crossing um I happen to
know that stretch pretty well cuz it
borders um um I'm I'm I'm in the
adjacent Ward um can you just confirm
though at this moment in time if someone
was crossing from that particular site
to the the motorway side of the
a4100 what facilities would be there to
encourage that they would want to cross
that road so they would need a Crossing
before the other phases come on board
I'm not talking about a a Crossing I'm
talking about coming from the bellway
way site along the b4100 into light horn
Heath Village to use the school The
Village Hall the Children's Center so
you're talking about a Crossing
to same side of the road but people
still got to walk alongside the
traffic is that a question or
comment if you're going to make a
comment could you put put your
microphone on if not we'll we'll move on
I think you've escaped no counciler
thank you very much you turn your mic
off
please uh right can we have our next
speaker please which is the r
edcom hopefully I've pronounced your
surname correctly there yes I didn't
choose that
name I think my wife says exactly the
same about mine as
well hear me you need to press the
button
okay fair enough you've got 3 minutes
and again would you like a warning with
about 30 seconds to go yes please
brilliant so far away when you're ready
thank you okay I've put some pictures
that I sent forward um basically I live
at three commanders close um it's the
house that's the most densely populated
out of all of the existing residents
there is three sets of affordable
housing looking into our back garden and
another two um we've been working with
way to try and come to a resolution if
you look at this picture which is the
first one that backs straight onto the
Culvert so we don't have a back Garden
there this was approved in around 2000
as Tony said
um effectively creating the situation
that we're in now so for any of the
resident of three commanders clothes
whoever it would have been would have
been in a situation that I'm in now
which is those are bedroom one bedroom
two bedroom three living room kitchen
dining room that's all our inhabitable H
uh rooms and they all back on to the
development with the Culvert and the
potential for the
um what's it called gifted land so the
small amount of gifted land which would
effectively give us a back Garden that
no you wouldn't normally have um so
that's the first situation then if you
move on to the next picture no so that's
the front of the house which has no
inhabitable rooms just to give you an
idea there's no living room window on
the front if you can go on to the next
one please we rush right okay so this is
the view that people would see from
plots 80 8182 which is the affordable
housing which is the three Terrace
houses um I've tried to take it from the
from the point of which there would be
but I'm on the ground floor so they
would be looking down um that's our
living room window our other living room
window and our main bedroom and as you
can see they would be looking directly
into our back Garden there would be some
minimum Landscaping P um but as you can
see it would need a significant amount
and it would affect our quality of life
this is a serious intrusion serious
overbearing and I cannot understand when
there's 140 houses going onto that
property going on to that plot why you
can't be sympathetic to the small amount
of residents that are affected because
surely you can shift things around a bit
I know it's a bit more complicated than
that can you go on to the next picture I
think there's one with a little tree
right okay that tree there is actually
uh significantly bigger on the M on the
plot well it isn't that's that's
supposed to be part of the actual
Landscaping so you can see that doesn't
do anything so my concern is the fact
that my Quality of Life Will Go um I'll
effectively be a prison in my my house
um because I won't be allowed in my back
garden and all of our living space will
be looked into by far five houses
there's also a back alley that goes by
the Terrace houses and that is around 7
m from our bedroom window so there could
be people there smoking pot drinking
kids messing about 7 m from our bedroom
window this is affecting my life this is
real I know this is your job can I ask
you to this is real just complet finish
your sentence off and then done done
thank you very much thank you any
questions yes get the bars please yeah
the the implication I got that your
property or a property was 24 M
from no no it's 21 m to the plot
78 Tony will be able to verify that it's
21 M to plot 78
um the distance to the actual back
alley is about 7 m
and bearing in mind that we're just
getting minimum 21 m is a minimum we're
not getting any more than that no no no
I'm just
um I'm sure they said 24 you see no
afraid not I'll have the extra if it's
going I might have got it WR never mind
well T do you want to come in very yeah
just to clarify distances um the
measured distance from the back of plot
78 to the back of number three which is
Mrs edom's house is 21
M uh and this is the land that's
currently part of the uh field that Mrs
Edam overlooks which will be gifted um
to three and four commanders close so it
would be that buffer area so effectively
be a back Garden to Back Garden
relationship um and these are the uh
properties that Mrs Edom uh was
concerned about looking from the side of
the prop of the of the
garden did you
indicate I'll wait for technical
questions so can I just ask a question
um how much um have you been in
consultation with the developers and the
planoffice
what um it started July last year so the
fight's been going on for eight months
or so it's been horrendous um we
eventually did get belway did eventually
agree to gift in us some land which I'm
extremely grateful for that um and then
on
Friday um we got the revision that plot
79 would be moved an angle slightly um
but there's been um they've come to the
property and seen the situation so it's
Tony um this is a very unique house and
you can't just deal with it in isolation
in a normal standard environment um so
yes every objection I've put in I've put
my comments in um for every reiteration
of the plans and put my concerns about
plots 80 881 and
82 um I've emailed bway I've emailed um
Tony I've copied you in on a number and
then in desperation I think last week
last Thursday I emailed the counselors
when I found out that you was allowed to
do that um which I wasn't aware
before thank
you any further
questions thank you very much I think
think you you done very well explaining
what you had to explain so thank you
very much for
coming right uh can we have our next
speaker would you is Katherine
house you've got six minutes Katherine
um again would you like a warn in with a
30 seconds to go yes please okay far
away ready thank you good evening uh my
name is Cathy El of climon planning
representing bway homes for today's uh
application um as we've been going over
today or we've discussed already bway
homes has gone through various situ
ation uh and various pre-application and
post submission design changes to reach
the layout that has been presented to
you today for
approval we've sought to work with the
council and local residents and Parish
councils at all opportunities to deliver
a scheme that is in accordance with the
policy um regarding the new settlement
and also your normal development control
policies in in respect of Separation
distances residential open space and
Landscaping
provision we have specifically sought to
address matters that have been raised To
Us by local
residents um to a degree that the
council has advised us is
acceptable for amendments to the layout
the impact of existing on existing
residents sorry has been
mitigated um as already touched on this
is meant transferring
um or to be transferred an area of land
to residents of commanders close and
what must be qualified here is that the
land to be transferred does have a width
of 10 m um from the scaled plans and
that we will work with the residents to
make sure they are landscaped and
bounded to their acceptabilities
um we're quite happy to accept a
planning condition regarding those
details um all along the southern bound
in addition we provide uh acoustic
fencing to the uh residential units this
will reduce nuisance disturbance as well
as dealing with outline conditions
regarding road
noise we've relocated the apartment
block away from existing residents to an
area that we don't feel is
intrusive sorry
M okay okay um in addition um bway homes
have submitted a construction management
plan that will seek to mitigate the
impacts of the construction phase to
local
residents with respect to additional
planting um that will be delivered we'll
make sure that that southern boundary is
as green as possible which is one of the
main feedbacks that we've had from local
residents as Tony touched on earlier the
design of the dwellings has been
informed by feedback we've received
we've designed a specific Parkland Edge
involving stone wood and balconies to
ensure that there's a different
environment to the edge of this new
settlement this was a as sorry this was
as a direct result of feedback from the
parish council so we hope that they
understand that we have gone to some
degree to reach their design aspirations
the layout presented also includes all
of the affordable housing that is
required through the section 106
agreement through amendments to the
seven boundary we've relocated the
majority of rental affordable properties
at the request of residents and then the
properties that will remain affordable
along this boundary will be shared
ownership properties where young
professionals will have the opportunity
to buy homes at a discounted rate
in addition the scheme will deliver
connections through this development to
the existing Village there is the
potential for a link to the school which
is being negotiated and will hopefully
come through in time but as a part of
the outline consent we will deliver the
new pavement along the
b4100 and this will provide suitable
access for people wanting to access the
facilities in the village
already in addition the reserve matters
have sought to deal with all of the
outline conditions that have been
attached and we have also addressed
ecological concerns raised by local
residents in respect of protected
species this is through the construction
management plan and direct discussions
with natural England
I trust that you can support your
officer's recommendation and approve
this first phase of a new settlement um
if you have any questions please let me
know thank you very much well within the
time catch the Parry
then thank you and good evening can you
just explain why the um area of Green
Space was allocated to the north of the
site rather than perhaps um being in the
south of the site which would have
provided a green buffer for the
residents in like horn Heath
Village um the area of Green Space um
accommodates the sustainable drainage
facility that serves um this development
it's typical for those sorts of um
drainage facilities to be within the
open space um and that is located due to
due to topography and also the
connection
to the drainage Beyond so that's why
it's dictated that's why it's gone to
the
north um the speed limit along that
road the
b400 yes yeah what is
it last time I drove along it I think it
was 30 40 I'm not very good at
remembering speed limits it was 40 today
yeah the point really
is why do the children have to walk on a
obviously a dangerous
road um at that you know 40 miles an
hour you know we really need some sort
of effort to get that sorted well in
terms of school children we hope to be
able to provide a DI link from the cycle
way into the school on the southern
boundary so that would would that would
remove school children from walking
along the b400
completely um in terms of providing a
new pavement along the b400 all the way
through to light forhe Village um that's
a that's a condition of this phase so we
will have to produce that so that
there's a new path along there um as
part of the wider settlement there are
other works to the b400 some of which
have already been approved as part of
the local Center um Crossing Arrangement
and that is going through technical
approval as we speak with the highway
Authority the other components of the
scheme on the other side of the road are
delivering that separately and that will
be delivered hopefully alongside the
construction works of this development
so we can't just consider this first
phase in in isolation because the
mitigation that's coming forward through
the outline consent will be delivered
alongside thank you thank you cancor
field and then canc s I've got two
questions one is
the uh uh
posos with regards if I got the right
initials public open space yeah who what
sort of management plan are you putting
in place on that um The Wider um
settlement in terms of the ceg Birdland
are put putting in place a management
company uh with the land trust and that
will also cover this
side so who is going to be responsible
for maintaining it is that going to be
put through a company owned by or run by
the uh residents or is it going to be
one run by yourselves it won't be in
this instance it won't be a bway homes
managed scheme and it won't necessarily
be a direct um scheme managed by these
residents it will be a management trust
that manages the whole settlement that
is being set up separately by C and Bird
Land
doners so is there the chance then that
there's going to be service charges
imposed on the new occupi there maybe I
I I haven't got those
details and the other question was
fencing around the site I I know you're
going to put a 1.8
meter uh from what hides The Village Sor
the vage but is the rest going to be
post and rail or is it going to be in
keeping with the countryside um along
the frontage to the
b4100 there were conditions placed on
the outline consent that required
acoustic fencing uh We've submitted
specifications and also a noise report
that demonstrates the boundary fencing
that we're providing through this scheme
meets those conditional
requirements um because a lot of the
fencing will be back of go Garden they
will be simple 1.8 um close boarded
fencing um at this moment in time there
isn't any um fencing to the front
Gardens for example I thinking of the
boundary um the boundary has to have um
Green Landscaping so it will be through
um structural planting and that's again
through the outline planning Mission so
I think a lot of these have been' done
through the planing already so I think
that was the I think that was the time
yeah we're following what was yes fine
Kathy yes fine thank you can say yeah um
we're talking here about um a particular
resident that's just spoken to us Mrs
edcom and in her message to
us it's clear that uh the stress and
strain of this whole situation is not
Mak is not doing our health any
good um and you produce a new set of
drawings
Mr Tony has has told us about the
dimensions being adequate Mr Horton and
I I believe that um but uh Mrs Edam says
she's asked you to be sympathetic to her
plot of feeling terribly crowded in when
the development's completed so is it
just a question of facing up to
distances between Properties or have
there been other things that you've
considered that she's mentioned to you
um in terms of the discussions that I've
had with Mrs Edom and also the
correspondence that we've received um as
you know we've we've had a lot of
meetings uh with local members Parish
councils um officers and local
residents um to to seek to resolve the
issues that they've raised and address
concerns so the relocation of the
apartment um was especially supported by
some of of the residents on Stonebridge
Road um in terms of the Commander's
closed properties especially Mrs Edkins
when we visited the site and
appreciated um the
narrowness of that boundary separation
that has led bway to
gift um an area to her that will
effectively double the garden space and
present a 10 m buffer within her own
ownership where we will work with her
and also her neighbor to provide a
planting scheme that hopefully she will
have control over and that will address
the concerns that she's raised I know
the point that she raised about the tree
um being not significant and not
sufficient that's not our intention Our
intention is to work with her and her
neighbor to provide a planting scheme
that that provides that
Landscaping it we did not feel it was
within within our place to specify that
without having those detailed
discussions with her and that's why
we're accepting a planning condition on
any any resulting consent that requires
us to do that okay I think you've
answered that quite well I think is
there is a condition condition seven is
part of a part of the report right I
don't think there's any further
questions um you're free to go thank you
uh we'll now move on to our next speaker
which is councelor Kettle who's
substituting for the ward member and a
joining Ward
member hopefully he switched his phone
off now so we don't have to hear that
anymore you've had your KN Knuckles WRA
there canel Kettle
um firstly um thank you Mr chair my pH
off I apologize for that it was actually
the had a paid service ringing me so I I
apologize anyway
um just point of clarification uh I'm
not presenting on behalf of councilor
Harris uh I believe that you have the
text of
her statement I'm very happy to read it
on your behalf if you like
but there was a very little there was a
small comment from councelor Harris
asking councelor Kettle to be available
um and the comment was that she
supported the pis council at their views
so Council the
cancel Kettle sorry
cancor
um as agreed we agreed that councelor
kettle would would make a small
statement on behalf as the joining board
member as well thank you thank you for
that clarification I emphasis on small
statement yeah yeah it is yeah I never
do anything but you know that Mr
chairman um I am the joining W Ward
member uh so my residents are actually
remote from this site uh but as members
will be fully aware um I have been um
significantly involved in this site from
the very ear early days and particular
uh worked with um former head of
planning policy Mr sorry can I confirm
Mr Fielding is with
us um that the uh I work consider with
David Nash uh in preparing the
supplementary planning document the
master plan for this site um um and that
is a document which we have to look at
when putting this when reviewing this
application a huge amount of work went
into that I wasn't particularly happy
with the master plan but the council has
adopted it so there we are um I'm also
fully aware because I have been involved
the huge amount of work that officers
have done on this and he's he's referred
to the outline or the plans going from a
to S I think you said Tony um and that
there has been significant movement um a
development of this size is always going
to cause concern to existing residents
on this site um and very regrettably
that is the way the planning system
works um there will be people who feel
hard done by by's
application uh but we have a an approved
outline application we have a master
plan and therefore this application does
sit within both those two documents we
we have you we are supporting the
principle of development on this site
the only points I would make on that
basis are four and they're very quick
ones so again just make it clear that
these are yours on behalf of with
councelor Harris's these are these are
mine as are joining Ward members
comments what you've agreed those with
councelor Harris as well I have managed
to get hold of councelor
Harris I was told as a joining W member
I was going to give an opportunity to
speak
we yeah we just need to make clear that
um that as a joining Ward me sorry
you're AC a substitute really for cancor
Harris and you're putting the views over
that you've
agreed with her um either jointly all on
her behalf so I think that was the real
point of council Harris and I have
discussed this over many months uh and
attended a number of different briefings
etc etc the actual wording what I'm
about to say is not something which has
been scripted with councelor Harris this
evening
sorry sorry cancer Kettle I've just been
advised that um counc barns please come
on thank you um I've just been advised
that although you've been discussing
with these with councelor Harris on a
long unless they are an agreed form of
words between
yourselves they can't just be your
opinion so that's the clarification I
was trying to see
there that does give me slight concern
Mr chairman because on each of these
applications the outline application
councelor Mills who's not present
councelor Harris who is not present and
I have all been invited to speak as um
either specifically or joining Ward
members in fact the outline appliation I
as an outlined War member was given uh I
think five minutes to speak on this
matter yeah I remember that and
therefore I think on that basis I would
suggest that the president has been set
on this site uh this is a unique site uh
that it would be appropriate I mean I've
only got four very brief points to make
as well Mr chairman it'll be finished by
the time we could have had this
conversation can I I just clarify point
there the outline permission covered a
much wider area and it covered all three
members Wards so they were speaking as w
Ward members not a joining Ward
members chair so he's got to speak on
behalf councelor Harris just for this
application Reserve matters it's as as a
Johnny W member he cannot speak that
right then sorry about that skettle so
on on the basis therefore that councel
Harris endorsed what exactly what the
parish council would say I emphasize one
point in that as councelor Harris got a
a comment a written
comment no so have you got anything that
we we can say that Council Harris has
given you to to speak or endorse or or
not Mr chairman if you don't wish to
hear my comments uh which I have
discussed with Council Harris then I
think that is regrettable um and um I I
think uh we are looking here at a
significant development I understand we
have protocols but we have had a
precedent on this and I accept exactly
what uh Mr Garden is saying that this is
part of that original application
outline application but I would suggest
it be appropriate of this occasion that
um since in the absence of the ward
member that members of the committee
should at least be allowed to hear what
um an adjacent Ward member which did at
one stage represent this site should be
consider should should I recommend that
members should be allowed to hear
it I would suggest it's in your
discretion as as well as chairman to
hear what might be
said okay I think that's quite clear I
think that obviously the original
outline plan was the master plan which
covered three different parish cils and
Wards so that was why the 15 minutes was
allocated between yourself councel Mills
and councelor
Harris um this is specifically for Lon
Heath Parish Council making sure I've
got the right way have a i counselor
Heder right thank you um and therefore
because council haris is the ward member
even though you're a joining one and you
used to represent this woman before the
boundary
changes I've been advised that unless
you've had some briefing that you can
assure us that Council house has given
you these words to speak or I give you
the points to raise on her behalf or
you've got a written documentation I'm
going to have to not allow you to speak
on this I think the matter lies in your
discretion Mr chairman uh we don't have
binding rules on this matter it is a
matter of discretion and I'd rather hope
that members of the committee would
benefit from hearing what I've got to
say I think reluctantly even though I'm
sure your points will be very relevant
can schle I'm afraid I'm not allowed to
speak on this
one right thank you for that um sorry
about that and sorry about the delay but
we have to make sure this clear so we'll
now move on to points of clarification
for
Tony Chris could you yeah sorry I
thought you were poined to councel Parry
two points Mr chairman on page
10 there is a um comment from the SDC
Conservation
Area and although we had the materials
mixed uh explained to us in some detail
by Tony
hton it says materials mix offers
variety but goes too far I couldn't
quite understand what that
meant and in the next point bullet point
down it talks a about
um the uh concept of traditional
elevations and materials representing
neighboring settlements and character in
the
areas um not convincing in the house
designs now that seems to me two
negatives in response to this whole
situation and uh I wondered if uh we
could have some explanation as to just
what those statements which have
obviously been abbreviated mean
yeah certainly yes the um the scheme
that the conservation officer was
commenting on was the initial scheme and
that did have um a plethora of materials
um which we agreed with the conservation
officer that there was too too many
materials in the scheme it included for
example um black wooden boarding which
is not characteristic of the district um
so we worked with bway to rationalize
the the number of materials and the type
materials and that came through in a
revised materials plan um and in terms
of the the house designs on the
character um bway through the process uh
initially started with three stone
houses and through the process they've
amended that and there's no 12 stone
houses in key strategic locations uh to
improve on that and to reflect the
character of the the local
vacular MR par
thank you chair um I just wonder whether
um I could have clarification on the
Topography of the site from the
residential side does it slope downwards
is it flat or does it or is there an
incline to the
site yeah in terms of the topography the
highest part of the site is in this
Southeast corner and the um the Contours
run down so you're going down slope as
you go in this direction and in this
direction so lower part of the site is
where the S attenuation P Pond is there
um so the houses on the site in general
will be no higher than the houses um in
terms of the the levels that are on
Stonebridge Road and commanders close
effectively the The Field's sloping away
from
them but they won't they won't be lower
they'll be similar similar he to saying
finish floor levels need to be approved
still through the process but there'll
be uh a similar uh level to the but not
but not higher than no there shouldn't
be any higher in terms of the the ground
levels
no I was just wondering about this
footpath looking at it there's an
entrance where we're coming in in the
middle we've got a cycle way in the
bottom which I assume is a foot path to
school
have we got on the outline is it 1.2 M
which is for single people or is it 2.4
M for two boogies to pass um because it
was a dangerous road this afternoon what
it's like when people are going to work
I have my concerns so what is the
stipulation of the foot
path or footway as it's called
today yeah the footway cycle way which
runs along here and connects through to
the B for 100 is 3 MERS
wide that will link through
to let me
just go through the cycleway then the
footway cycleway runs along there
there'll be separate Pavements
throughout the site um but this footway
C we get to the main road how wide is
the foot yeah so it' be a 3 m wide
footway Cycle Way which runs down the
b400 the school the school down here
isn't it yeah uh let's I don't know
whether I've the School site this is the
back end of the school so these are the
school playing fields and some rougher
area with the school okay the intention
is to work with the school to try and
get some kind of gated uh link from the
cycleway here into the school not been
done yet it's not been done yet but the
parish council um are working with the
school to try and Achieve that and B web
said that they'll facilitate
that um I've got a couple questions turn
one uh on page 10 Again from the
conservation officer mentions the
maximum Heights of two and 2.5 story and
councelor haer mentioned the three story
regarding the flats so I just wonder
what that point was and again Council
had you
mention the infrastructure um what was
the
um that some of the infrastructure
wouldn't be there before this was built
and the potential effects of
that yes so in terms of the
apartments
uh best if I get the apartment um
elevations up just bear with
me right
so chairman the um the the height of the
apartments are technically three story
there they've been reduced in height
during the process um the uh gain light
on Heath SPD talks about uh a 2.5 meter
story height and the parameter plan for
the site talks about twostory height the
parameter PL condition to be in general
accordance with so I think my report
says that 96% of the the the dwellings
on here Accord with the parameter plan
so we would say that's General
accordance the one exception is the uh
apartment block which is three-story and
goes above that 10 10 meter limit to
10.9 oh in in terms of the
um um the point raised about the
infrastructure um the key things are
note is obviously there's an outline
permission um for uh the vast majority
of the new settlement and that will
deliver various bits of infrastructure
in due course uh and Council offices are
progressing well with um th that part of
the scheme um so there's no doubt that
the rest of it won't come forward um if
it weren't to come forward what I would
say is it's on the edge of a local
service Village lior Heath which is
actually quite High the hierarchy in the
core strategy uh lior Heath is in
Category 2 lsv so it has a good range of
services so in the the the very un usual
event that nothing else would have come
forward but this it's still a
sustainable site according to our core
strategy in terms of infrastructure and
Services I think could I just add to
that as well chairman that um there are
section 106 payments from um the
development which will go to Lon Heath
Village to improve their infrastructure
and facilities and those triggers are
through the buildout process and the
bellway site if it's built out will'll
trigger some of those payments I think
probably about 125,000
more than the
fiing I just want to go back to the
distances from Commander number three
commanders um close to the houses
behind oh
God where are you you are you I I
presume that the the usap with g is on
either side of a house is that
correct that's right if I just um zoom
in on that so it's more
apparent so what we have is the main
houses so did you take the distance from
the garage or did you take it from the
actual house to come to the 24 M the 21
M 21 it the 21 M comes from uh a
standard which is part of the council
standards that main habitable window
window distances should be 21
M keeping and those window distances are
in 21 M and in keeping with the
standards um distances of single story
uh garages there's no standard for
distances away from um for dwellings in
that case I'm not so worried about the
garages what I'm worried about is the
overlooking of the gardens which was
something that was referred to or the
house yeah in terms of overlooking of
gardens the distance that's required is
10 m from a a window to a boundary with
a garden so we've got that distance
achieved and then you've got another 10
m then another 10 m yes so yes 21 m in
total thank you very much should we move
on to the debate
now K
par thank you chair
um I think first of all I would like to
say I I do understand
the the stress um and the difficulties
that the
neighbors uh local
residents um have felt particularly over
all all this sort of planning um and all
all the various plans and amendments but
it is refreshing to see that a developer
have from what I've heard this evening
um has certainly worked has done their
best in a in a challenging situation
certainly to to come forward by amending
plans uh from my experience it's very
unusual for a developer to gift a fairly
sizable piece of land to extend a garden
um so that is particularly welcoming um
and whil I do have every sympathy for
residents I know it's very difficult
when you have um a development that
comes right up towards you and you you
do lose your views of Fields but
unfortunately the planning system um we
have all lived in h well a number of us
have lived in houses where we have lost
our view
um I can't see any planning
reason uh to refuse this
application um and therefore I will be
going with the officer's
recommendation p c
v
yes I'm sort of a similar mind it's just
a shame that the rest of the site seems
to be okay and we got the bit of the
bottom it isn't okay I appreciate
they've given a bit of garden but
otherwise they wouldn't have the houses
there and they three stories so um you
know it's one thing the other concern is
getting to
school um I don't think the developers
well she said the parish council were
thinking of doing something well as far
as I'm concerned you know that's not
really good enough concerned about the
road and the foot path but in planning
terms um that's another reason for
refusal um I would like it to go back
and be finished off or whatever but
we're not in that situation so um I will
have I'm quite happy to Second The
Proposal
counc
fing I'm quite happy with with what um
councilor Perry has said the only thing
that concerns me is this matter of the
POS and putting the management of this
particular site which is more or less
Standalone in with the rest of the
development when it takes place um
because of the abuse that can can take
place with management fees and
everything else I would have thought
it's much better if it was managed by
the Village or trust within the
village just be managed by trust yeah I
think it's going to be managed by a
trust and then sometimes I don't think
the village or the parish council wants
to take it on I know some do but some so
we can't make the the assumption that
they might want to take
out that was just my
observation um and we we spoke about the
link um Briton proposed link isn't it
ran the back towards the school
um which I believe the agent and I think
Mr Horton has said that the agent in the
school are potentially working on that
with a gated access uh through the I
think it was called The Ash path if I
was remember rightly um next application
next one so I I believe there is a A Way
Forward on that but it it
is however welcome it would be is not
actually forming part of this proposal
at the moment so that's one thing I
think we need to make clear is is not
guaranted that will take place this that
right we approve this we've got no
guarantee that's going to be done if we
if we you know defer this until the
school thing's done then we do know it's
going to get done we don't want to do
that but it is
important yeah just to clarify the
position about links to the school um
the outline permission requires the
development of this site to deliver a
footway cycle way from the site running
down the b400 and then cutting into
gford Road um if I just get back to the
access uh slide that I showed before
push bikes and prams don't go
together so this is a three meter wide
um footway Cycle Way which has ample
room for foot cycles and um pedestrians
to pass one another it's got these
cuttings to gford road which allows then
uh school children and parents to access
through to the
school separately to that um bway the
parish council um and ourselves have
been in discussions with County
Education to try and get the link
through to the school directly from the
site that hasn't been possible yet but I
don't think bway should be penalized for
that b said that they will facilitate
that if it can come if it can happen
otherwise the alternative is the
conditioned forway cycleway which is was
always going to be the link um
guaranteed by the outline condition
there's also um the longer term
possibility of I've talked about this
link at the the back end of the site
through to the sports facilities the
longer term possibility is that when
that's um provided you will then get a
link through which will link to the
ashra and to the school um in in that
longer term process so there's three
possibilities here one which will
definitely have to happen before they
can occupy which is the beef 100 footway
cycleway one which will happen in the
longer term around the back and one
which needs the school to agree to
it coun
science yes chairman I think in the
discussions that we've had uh and the
answers he's given which I can
compliment him on but his thoroughness
and Clarity uh Tony hton said we're up
to version s i
of the uh of the various plans and he'
started at version a which is
understandable I'm sitting here thinking
do we need another version do we need a
version T to be in a position to to
approve this because there seems to be a
lot of niggly little things still to
sort out um and I'm not suggesting that
we should demand the sorting out of the
school access here um although I don't
know where the proper access is I was
going to ask that on the next
application but the thing is um we do
have a situation whereby clearly um the
resident of three commanders close feels
that uh we or she feels particularly
crowded out and I'm sure some small
modifications could be done to to to to
mitigate that
situation so I'm looking perhaps for
another version of the plan rather than
approve the one we've got
now coun fa then can could it not be
left for you and the planning officer to
finalize his various points rather than
going to T and
another yeah could you just we have to
address bots in front of us and this is
what is in front of us
yeah I'm I'm concerned
that you we might go from from a to S we
might even go to a to zed by the time
we've gone through all the finding
points it's delay in the process yes
there are concerns but whatever
application we have in front of us is
very very very rarely perfect so I think
sometimes we have to do look at the plan
and balance look what we've got in front
of us well that's exactly my comment but
they're just the niggly little bits that
need to find tune it but I don't don't
think we need to go to Beyond s okay
thank you thank
you counc Pary chairman could I just
come in and say that I'm happy to
propose grant for this
application I'll second
it
so yeah do whatever you want how wide is
the cycle way there I think it was room
I think it was 3 meters Tony was it yeah
so we've had a propos on a seconder uh
with the to agree to the amended
recommendation in the update sheet
condition and we're going to delete
condition nine
um so we'll we'll go to the vote all
those in favor of
approval three chairman
against two chairman
two committee agrees to approve the
recommendation
including
the the appr amended recommendation and
the update sheet and deleting condition
not thank you chair and we need to have
a slight small adjournment now because
we're going to be moving
officers thank
you
e
um thank you very much for the slide
adjournment whilst one two things were
saw did it we've had excuse me we've had
a slight change of plan Uh something's
cropped up um slight emergency that
we've had to slightly re jiggly order on
the agenda tonight so instead of it
being um
land adjacent to verie road light on
heat from then moving on
to application number six excuse me
which is 18 03612 ful and
613 RBC for 13 to 15 High Street ships
on um so sorry about that and thank you
for people bearing with us on this
application and uh Joe will be
presenting this one thank
you thank you
chair the application site is located of
1315 High Street ships and on Stow as a
black dot before you
indicates the building is a grade 2
listed building and lies within the
shipon style Conservation Area
pedestrian access from The High Street
is from three access points a passageway
either side of the shop and the shop
doorway itself the shop and the office
occupy the front part of the building
with a dwelling house at the rear the
dwelling is in separate
ownership this is a Google Earth of the
application site it's indicated by the
red line boundary this is the
application site when sh on Star and
within the conservation
area the application is seeking to
change the use of the first and second
floor offices to a single apartment
including Associated internal
alterations to f to facilitate the
conversion no no external works are
being proposed as part of this
[Applause]
application Plan before you shows the
basement and ground floors existing as
you can see the shop um shop front is is
at the front of the ding at the building
sorry store at the back and so forth and
then the basement
area this is the existing plans of the
first and second floor offices at the
minute with the vacant offices on both
floors the plan before you shows the
extent permission for two apartments
granted at committee on the references
17364 and
17036 07
LBC as you can see the plans are for you
the first rule was apartment one
and the second floor was apartment
two the plan on the screen demonstrates
that the ground floor offices will
remain as
is and the plan before you now
demonstrates how the department will be
divided into one a dwelling so the first
floor is living accommodations such as
living room dining
area um kitchen area utilities floor
area second floor would be obviously
sleeping quarters in the
bathrooms this is a direct photo of the
uh building in question Peter Clark's
shot there the estate agents Cooperative
next to it and
London London dressing uh quarters the
other side first floor apartment
dwelling there second Flo apartment
there this gives you an indicative look
out of the street scene as you can see
D's there this fronts on to L's Bank on
the area across from the area is the
white render buildings and looking down
the street to the side is white render
wood
brick this view is taken on the second
floor within apartment complexes so at
the minute they're the vacant offices
but they Overlook onto the dwelling uh
behind it as well as the property of the
BMB be and the hotel it's being run
behind this is where you see the deck in
the seating area just
outside this is a view from the first
floor kitchen Diner so you taken just
there you see the views
across an area of L just adjacent
there and these are views from the
second floor so two windows there taken
straight out onto the D onto the B&B
area we can see the seated area is and
same again just slightly bl by the OB uh
by the
vegetation this plan before you here
shows the relevant parking areas the
square area shows the dwelling parking
area to the front public parking area to
North to rear there is some public
parking area as well and then further to
Southeast that's the end of the
presentation a officer recommendation is
for
approval and if you to have a look on
the update seat on page 71 paragraph 5
of the committee report it states the
vacant office floor space equates to 161
square meters and therefore would
require eight additional spaces to serve
the offices this is significantly less
than the pros demand of two additional
spaces that's this small typo it should
State the vacant office floor space
equates 61 square m and therefore would
require eight additional spaces to serve
the offices this is significantly more
than the proposed demand of two
additional
spaces thank
you can we have our first speaker
please which is the agent Mr
Murphy thank you Mr
Murphy we've got uh 3 minutes
would you like at warning with about 30
seconds to go I think I'll be okay
thanks good man thank you very much far
away thank you chairman the entire
building was historically one house
later the ground floor became
commercialized and is currently an
estate agents the rear wing is a bed and
breakfast in separate ownership and is
not part of this
application in 2009 the upper floors
were converted to offices for 18 years
was only one office tenant and they left
in January
2017 the upper floors are currently
empty in March
2018 planning permission was granted to
change the use of the first and second
floor offices to Two
Flats the upper floors are in the
process of being sold to the current
applicant who wants to live there in one
flat on the first and second floor hence
the current application is to develop
the upper floors as one flat rather than
two shipston Town Council do not object
and nor does anyone else except for
councelor Saint he objects on the
grounds of lack of parking and
overlooking his objection is completely
irrational the front part of the listed
building has no parking and never will
parking is available on the high street
or in the large 24-hour free public car
park to the rear a future occupier might
rent a garage or not own a car at all
this is a town center location well
served by
buses at the moment the council does not
have adopted parking standards how
however even if the draft standards were
taken into account there is no conflict
the current lawful use is offices and
that generates a parking demand of eight
spaces the extant permission for Two
Flats granted only last year generates a
parking demand of three
spaces the proposed One Flat generates a
parking demand of two
spaces so this proposal of one flat will
result in a substantial reduction in
parking
demand councilor Saint also refers to
the overlooking of the bed and breakfast
accommodation to the rear however there
are no new windows
proposed the existing Windows do not
Overlook any habitable rooms in the bed
and
breakfast the offices overlook part of
the rear yard sometimes used by tourists
likewise the approved Two Flats and the
proposed One
Flat uh both Overlook the same part of
the rear yard and in fact this proposal
uh changes sorry the proposal for Two
Flats had uh a first floor uh kitchen
Diner whereas this proposal has a
bathroom window which will be OB skill
glaze and so they will actually be even
less
overlooking now the bed and breakfast
owner has no objection to this
application no doubt in recognition that
one flat is less intensive than two
flats and is less intensive than offices
so in summary Council of saints
objection has no merit and I ask you to
Grant planning permission and listed
building consent thank you thank you
that was spot on any questions for the
agent okay the
fing clarify is it going to be um a
three-bedroom unit it is yes cuz there
is an indication if we can go to the
right hand plan there if you can enlarge
it now the other way the first floor
bedrooms is that a bedroom that's split
in two
there yeah there there I there that's
bathrooms yes it's bathrooms yeah so
bathroom two is what's proposed the
previous scheme for Two Flats that was
proposed as a kitchen Diner or be with a
different config obviously
larger and can we have our W member
please councelor
Sint
thank you chairman well having been
accused of being decidedly irrational
and speaking without any substance I'm
now going to be rational and speak with
some
substance first of all the present in
officer referred to the thing on the
update sheet about having eight spaces
if the building were going to be used
for uh commercial use which they have
been since
2009 but that's
irrelevant absolutely totally crass and
irrelevant because nobody's using that
space as
offices and in any event the office
space car parking will be during the day
and and uh residential parking
presumably will be
247 now secondly in his
presentation um Mr Brooke showed
everybody where the car parks
are they showed them where the Stratford
District car parks are and they're not
relevant to this application because as
somebody says or the report
says um there's been a consultation it's
a a consultation following a
consultation which I shall come to in a
moment and effectively I have the
consultation
here and what it said was I can flick
through it I could show it to you
there's an awful lot of red in there but
it says revised part incorporating
amended parking standards amended
parking Bay sizes and other minor
amendments now other minor amendments to
what there must have been a predecessor
to this document and the consultation
closed on the 15th of March and
therefore I think we can give it far
more weight than he
implies and there's another reason for
that as well and that
is that uh effectively this
document uh was preceded by another
version
which the cabinet of January 2018 of
which I was the
chairman so I know and I know what went
through and we approved it approved um a
revised parking policy it's been decided
since that that wasn't good enough and
therefore should be further amended but
it's nonetheless approved yet the report
makes no mention of this it's as if it
didn't exist when it did and and I would
have suggested that that represents some
policy which we can give
weight now the problem I have with the
parking situation and it's something
you've heard me say before including the
version of this uh that he's referred to
I thought M and Nash was always fond of
telling us that we have to uh make a
decision on what's before us I agree
with him nobody spot on so why have we
been told about an application that was
approved two or three years ago
irrelevant totally
irrelevant because the point is that was
also opposed by me and I probably didn't
make such a good job of Defending my
line as I'm hoping I am tonight now the
important thing here is the Town
Council the Town Council um somewhere in
the report
says that they don't have an objection
so long as the application complies with
current parking policy I don't think it
does and I don't think it does for the
reason I've just said the decision that
was made by cabinet in January
2018 now also at that time last time I
discussed parking matters with Mr Brooke
we were talking about the shipston car
parking
study now I'd like him to tell me what
he's done with that conversation
and whether he's looked at it if he's
short of it I have a copy of it
here and what is most important with
these ships and car parking is it looks
at the total dir of
applications total dir of availability
of car parking in the town center and I
know CU I'm the ward member for the Town
Center so I get all the complaints from
the public they can never find anywhere
to
park seconds okay so consequently what
I'm saying is that that effectively uh
validates the preliminary uh policy that
was passed some 15 months
ago and therefore makes it that I'm
limited with time obviously I'd like to
talk about overlooking but I don't think
I'm going to have time because I had
representations in the neighbor about
overlooking on the previous application
okay can I thank you very much I think
you have slightly got that point over
with some forbearance by himself there
um questions for the ward
member no I you've either done a very
good job there can say you've answered
all their
questions or we're waiting for some
points for clarification so thank you
very
much the points of
clarification
thank you chair could I just have some
further clarification on the parking
policy which I um I understand has not
been adopted it is just in its draft
stages sorry and to add therefore the
weight to give to parking policy when
it's in its draft
stages yeah thank you councelor uh so in
draft stages it has limited weight so in
consideration of the application we do
have to look at what the examp
permission is which is two dwellings
that's what I referred to in the report
we have to consider the existing use
because it hasn't been undertaken from
the estamp position so that's why both
applications refer to in report it has
limited weight as such and then highways
Authority will also consulted and raise
no objection so combined of all that
including draft requirements SPD it was
decided that in terms of Highways
objections we couldn't as an officer
couldn't recommend
refusal I've got a couple of questions J
first
the um regarding the parish
council
so they've put no objection in or it's
been classed as no
objection but there's the
caveat with the requirements of the
emerging parking standards so how how
does that sit how does that square that
they're not objecting but there sort of
might
be was highlighted in the requirements
of the parking standards come forward it
does meet the parking standards or
technically there is no parking element
there but based on ships and onst being
sustainable location and I state with
parking standards and that lot we have
to take consideration regarding that
therefore it raised there's no
objection um regarding the application
especially once getting in connection
with existing USP offices and therefore
would technically reduce the parking
elements of it as stated in the parking
standards and also the extand
permissions for two dwellings and once
again reduces the parking elements and
the trip germination as stated within
the draft parking
standards and just a further one were
there any other objections to this or
letters of support I don't think I could
see anything in the report but no there
wasn't any comments or it was no
objections regarding
neighbors any
comments fing thank
you it refers to objections from the LBC
I presume that's a conservation
officer the design and access statement
is
flawed claims overlooking the B&B will
not John John
no that was the ward member it's the
this to building consent and the for
so it's it's a two-part one so it's
not that's whole purpose of the points
of
clarification right any other points of
clarification can the
sence thank you chairman I've asked the
speak a second time because I'm
concerned that Mr Brooke has decided
that the only policy document is this
one that's just been out for
consultation which is described as an
amendment and I said an amendment to
what and I said it's an amendment to
another policy document that was
approved in
2018 and therefore that must be uh
referred to in the answer to councilor
parry's question so your point out a
that was a point out a factum element of
fact that's why I've allowed you to come
back yeah okay I I'll let
Joe could you so yeah at the minute
there has been amendments to draft
policy requirements SPD to the parking
standards element of that requirement
SVD but it is still not an adopted
policy therefore it still carries
limited
weight counc oon so I think councilor St
was referring to the previous planning
policy
document um and that that would still
carry some weight wouldn't it if the upd
d one hasn't been approved or adopted
same yeah it technically the old parking
standards is technically out of date so
that you are correct it still carries
some weight in determination of
applications once again regarding them
requirements because there is no parking
actually associated with this
development including the existing uses
it doesn't technically meet that sort of
old cment document but once again in the
assessment you have to assess that they
are existing offices with no parking
standards and also examp permission that
has been approved at committee that also
has no parking at the minute so that's
the reason for the determination is on
the planning balance is the best way to
put
it right we all happy now we all
clarified good right should we move on
to the debate now
please Council
bars well over the years I've heard
Chris go on about parking in shipston
which is one of his great concerns I
suppose you could say fact at one
application about 10 years ago it was
suggested have a bike rack because some
of the car Parks were 24 hours and some
were 12 hours and you know so but as far
as I'm concerned I'm quite happy with
the application whether it's got a bike
rack or no car parking there's plenty of
room to park if you can look for it
so
that's
car thank you chair um I'm not sure
whether Council Barnes was putting
forward a proposal but it was yet um but
if Council Barnes is putting forward a
proposal I'm happy to second second it
on the basis there are no material
planning reasons to refuse this site and
the fact that the parking policy because
it's not been adopted carries limited
weight
K like to come in a second sorry just
for clarification purposes um the
application you have in front of you is
an application for one flat the
application you determined uh just
literally um a year and a couple of
weeks ago was put two Flats on the same
site and I recall that committee there
was a lot of debate about parking at
that time the determination of by the
committee was that you accepted two
Flats with no parking that permission
can be implemented and it could be
implemented for the next 2
years um that is a material
consideration and I appreciate the
debate around parking standards is
obviously of concern but the significant
material consideration is that this has
planning permission for Two Flats with
no parking what you have in front of you
is a proposal for one flat with no
parking that's the decision DEC ision
you're
making so what in front of you yeah we
again we just decided on what is in
front of us we can't put any extra
caveats onto it so I wasn't proposing to
put any further
caveats sorry if I was confusing I was
supporting and seconding the proposal
from counc bonds to
Grant much any other comments to Pate
we've had a proposal on the second so
all those in favor of approving the
application unanimous chair thank you we
do the listed building as well now
please and we need to do the listed
building element as well which is
application 18
LBC um again again uh are you willing to
propose Council
bar and second counc
odonnell so we've had a proposal on the
second to support approve the
application all those in favor unanimous
chair you committee resolves to approve
application 180 3613 LBC thank
you Cel BS thank you very
much on we'll move back
on
excuse pleas yep come on can we move on
to the next item on the
agenda which
is item number four application number
223f land adjacent toer road light on
Heath erection of 21 DWS included access
from ver Road and Associated ancillary
and enabling
works and Anthony will be presenting
this thank you Anthony thank you chair
so we're back in light horn Heath uh for
a much smaller scheme this is 21
dwellings and the dot marks the location
with on the edge of the settlement uh
where the site
is this is a site edged in red it's um
scrub at the moment and um just by way
way of background for members there is a
an extent planning permission on this
site for 10 dwellings uh which can be
implemented and the proposal is for 21
so that gives you an 11 net
increase so here we see it in relation
to Vernie Road lonn Heath primary school
just to the
left and uh the public foot path
otherwise known as the ash path running
along the south side which links to the
school and off to the right into the
settlement here we have a a layout um
there's been several iterations of this
layout and now we're at a position that
officers are able to recommend
approval part of The Proposal includes
uh the formalization of a footpath link
from the development uh which goes to
the Ash paath and then onto the school
which L links back to Vernie road so
that improves the connectedness of the
site and we have a mix of uh semi-
detached and detached
properties um the affordable units St
clustered around the bottom southern
part of the
site and the um the car parking
provision
um in light of the emerging um car
poging SPD it actually complies with
that
SPD um the draft
SPD so for members some photographs here
so it gives you an idea of the site as
you say it's um it's a sort of scrub
land site um Hawthorne sort of pioneer
species uh
Birch and uh Bramble and that sort of
thing is actually allocated as a a
wildlife site um in conjunction with the
Quarry Wildlife site that Tony was
talking about earlier so it's a sort of
satellite um site to that however the
site itself as I said is has an extent
permission so it could be developed
tomorrow and that would result in the
loss of any any ecology
benefit um for the members this
Photograph shows uh the current current
current informal p uh pedestrian link or
footway desire line through to the um
Ash path public path foot path here and
entrance into the school as you can see
it's a well-used uh muddy Trail and that
will be formalized into a proper
footpath
link and it emerges here just onto the
edge of Vernie
Road um just to give members an idea of
typical front elevations so simple in
form and design detailing uh
accommodating sort of more cottagey
style features such as brick Arch L
lentils and um chimneys open rafter feet
plain verges porches Etc cottage style
windows so overall uh would present a
sort of a villagey feel if you like and
just to give members context and what
this would actually be sitting alongside
are the properties um um on the opposite
side of the road um for Vernie road
again simple simple in form and
detail members the um the recommendation
is is to approve subject to the
conditions and um there are no updates
but I would like to suggest um a further
condition um um which would require that
the foot path remains new foot path
remains unobstructed at all times
therefore uh allowing me um um future
residents and existing residents the
benefit of uh um unrestricted access
through to the ash paath thank you
chair right thank you anony we'll go on
to our first Speaker again which is
councelor Maggie
hedger
and thank you for beinging with us
earlier much appreciated thank
you again three minutes we'll give you a
warning if you could 30 minute war that
would be
great Lys on Heath Parish Council
objects the proposal to Grant approval
for this application the application for
21 dwellings opposite existing houses on
ver road is gross over development and
does not reflect the local vernacular of
the existing properties and in no way
harmonizes with the locality it is
incompatible with the layout of the
Kingston Fields end of Lor Heath where
even the most recent infield
developments demonstrate more spacious
site planning in sympathy with the
larger semi- detached officer houses
that make up the Kingston Fields end
Additionally the proposed mix of 1 two
three and four bedroom dwellings are not
in keeping with the area from the first
of April light on Heath will become a
new Parish to incorporate the new
settlement known as GH Lor Heath Parish
Council believe it is unreasonable to
have to meet the local service Village
quota in addition to the GH housing
numbers the site sits within an
extremely narrow road with tight bends
at both ends we are extremely concerned
with regard to the increased traffic
flow along winet Road Bernie Road
Stonebridge road and gford road with a
potential increase of 40 or more cars
adding to the traffic load at the North
End Of The Village at peak times it is
already impossible for Refuge vehicles
or emergency vehicles to get through
when cars are parked on street which is
likely given such restricted on-site
parking given the high density of the
development you will see from the
committee report that this site has
several applications put forward over
the past 15 years and extent prop
approval has already been granted for 10
houses this is totally in keeping with
the environments of Kingston field end
and FY Road the proposal put forward
represents a 50% increase to the extent
consent and will create an overdeveloped
high density site the parish council
relieved to see a construction
management plan is conditioned and
request that the parish council is
consulted with regard to construction
access to the site and that contractor
parking is prohibited from the nearby
residential roads school car park and
that construction noise and Nuance
levels are strictly controlled finally
the parish council is extremely
concerned about the disruption and
inconvenience to local residents and
particular particularly commanders close
who will already be affected by the
building out of the application of the
140 houses on the L on the land west of
b4100 Lon Heath Parish Council requests
that the committee consider these points
when reaching a decision on this
application any questions for the par
councelor councelor
Donal good evening can I ask did the
developer engage with you in discussing
the increase in houses that would being
applied for no
okay I've got one cat the
Fielding sorry actually I've given an
incorrect answer there they have engaged
with the parish council in relation to
what the parish council might use
section 106 funding
for k f is the is the parish well SED
for um social or affordable homes or
will the seven that are coming forward
from the scheme add or be useful for the
number of people who want need to
downsize there are a number in the area
and of course they will also be able to
Avail themselves of the uh properties on
the uh 140 houses bellway development so
we don't see the need for an overcrowded
site can ask a question about the life
um immunity space um original extent
permission for 10 did that have any W
life mitigation measures because this
one seems to have um around about 100ks
worth of mitigation measures and I just
wondered what the difference was between
the two I couldn't answer that because I
didn't live in the parish at that time
so
I okie dokie thank you very much no
further questions
free to go yes thank you very
much and our next speaker is Emma
Greening the oh I didn't think Emma was
here for a
minute three minutes Emma um would you
like it warnning with 30 seconds yes
thank
you brilliant um thank you for allowing
me to address you this evening um first
like to thank officers who have sought
to work with the applicant throughout
this application which has resulted in a
balanced Report with a recommendation to
permit subject to the legal agreement
the development proposes a mix of 21 1 2
3 and four bedroom dwellings including
seven fixed Equity dwellings which will
be controlled through the section 106
agreement allowing local people the
opportunity to get onto the property
ladder the site is located within the
village with built development on all
sides and there's examp permission for
housing on the site throughout the
application process the applicant has
sought to make amendments taking on
board the comments from officers and
statutary
consules the development has been
carefully designed to ensure it is in
keeping and will complement the existing
dwellings on ver Road the proposed
dwellings front ver Road and
predominantly constructed a brick in a
simple design creating a strong Street
fontage and adhering to the council's
guidance on separation distances taking
into account the concerns raised by
local residents over parking the scheme
has been designed with adequate onsite
parking for all residents of the
development together with an appropriate
level of visitor parking this has been
designed in accordance to meet the
emerging higher parking standards of the
SPD um tracking requirements have also
been um carried out demonstrating that
refuged vehicles that can safely use
this site as well um furthermore The
Proposal allows for formalized footpath
to be created from ver road to the
public foot part to the south of site
which then provides an easy direct and
safe access to the adjacent primary
school for both the residents of the
development and within wi ver area ver
Road area itself significant PL
additional planting is proposed along
the boundary with the school as well as
within the site um following discussions
with the parish council it's been
determined that for public open space a
financial contribution would be the best
way forward towards an outdoor exercise
Trail overall in our view the proposals
make the most efficient use of the site
in line with government policy and will
result in a development which
complements the existing residential
homes on ver Road it will provide a mix
of dwellings together with fixed Equity
units in accordance with the council's
adopted policy it will provide a
formalized footpath link through to the
school and The Wider Village and as part
of this application Financial
contributions will be provided towards
an out outdoor exercise Trail
biodiversity offsetting together with
the SE contributions to be spent in the
local area um I'd like to thank you for
your time this
evening
good
evening um I wonder whether you can
explain why um there are no
one-bedroom dwellings which in
accordance with cor strategy cs19 policy
we look to have 5 to
10% and also on the
twoed mix um that doesn't conform either
to the 35 to 40% % recommended cs19 mix
yet your three bed and your four bed are
over the recommended CS um 19 mix okay
um I think there is one unit one of the
fixed equ units would be a one bed um
and I think as within the officer's
report here on when you've got quite a
small scheme it's often difficult to um
get an appropriate mix across the site
we've tried to do it in best but taking
into account the character the area
which is generally a three bed
properties we feel that we've put
forward a mix which is appropriate on
this
site um just to make sure uh clarify
that the
affordable element the seven properties
one would be one
bed three two
beds um two three beds and one four bed
is that if I've done my maths
correctly one bed one four bed
um I think it looks like yeah one one
one bed one four bed
three I thought
was I I thought it might be the other
way around three two beds and two three
beds looking at the report on page 37
and
38s yeah that's what that's what I
thought it would yep
super but not on the prob y okay y
that's that's fine thank you any
K the fixed Equity properties are the
these are not um being organized by
Housing Association they are being sold
at a discount is that correct um they be
they would be controlled through a legal
agreement um as a fixed discount which
would remain in perpetuity for future
sales on it and I think the council
guidance and their officers will correct
me if I'm wrong sets out that they have
to um be considered for local people
first there sort of a um threshold for
each one before it can be offered out to
The Wider area and what percentage of
discount are you offer looking at um it'
be a 40%
discount thank you I don't think there's
any further questions Emma I think
you're free to go thank you and can we
now move on to points of clarification
for
Anthony okay the filled in
then you have referred to the fact that
there was approval for 10 houses that's
current I was just looking through the
schedule of when all these planning
applications were were put forward and
the nearest one I've got is 07 when was
the one for 10
houses um actually granted and if so if
it's fairly recent have you got any can
you show us any images or what the 10
houses would look
like thank you counselor uh the original
outline went goes back to
2001 and then the 2003 Reserve matters
for 10 dwellings that was April
2003 and then the certificate of
lawfulness to to establish that the
development has commenced um dated back
to 200 December
2007 um the original applic well the
2003 appication some years back now and
I was looking out the the layout plan
but it was in such poor condition the
actual image had been stretched so it
really wasn't very representative but
what I can do I mean it was very
straightforward um there was um three
pairs of semi if you can follow my arrow
the three pairs of semi detach down down
here which took access directly off
Fernie Road there was a proposal for an
access similar to this and then
clustered around the uh access like a cu
the sack were for detached dwellings
around here so three pairs of semis down
here and then four detached clustered
around the cold
sack so that took up all basically the
all the space there it did yeah it
wasn't as cramped as it it it took up
all that space yes that's right it's
worth noting that um in the report I
mentioned that
um uh the nppf looks to ENC encourage
the efficient use of land obviously
providing it uh respectful of the
prevailing character and it's it's
always also noteworthy that in 2006 the
plan um the planning Authority refused
an application for nine dwellings saying
wasn't it wasn't dense
enough um that's um at page
36 so um officers feel now that um an
appropriate balance has been reached and
which also achieves significant uh cont
contributions including biodiversity
contribution which didn't exist on the
extant permission so there's a
significant benefit there we think thank
you
chair chairman can we have some uh
information please about access to the
school is it just along the footpath or
is there a vehicular access is there a a
pedestrian access somewhere that that
isn't available on these
plans so um as I said earlier um there's
a proposal part of The Proposal is to
formalize the um informal mudy access
track there that I showed the photograph
of which runs across the site and joins
up with the ash paath public right of
way which then takes you to the school
so where I've put the blue arrow there
that shows where that new path or new
foot footway will connect through to the
public foot path so formalizing an
existing formal Arrangement uh for the
benefit of existing and future residents
in terms of um access by by
car the the school will be accessed like
any other house in the village if people
choose to go by car but seemed quite
unusual if anyone wants to go to school
by car when the school is just around
the
corner thank you
chair F outlines where do the teachers
Park the their cars cuz appear that you
cuz I had I don't think this is relevant
John there is a parking area just south
of it yeah I don't think this is sorry
un it's not relevant to the appli yeah
okay um yeah just talking about on page
36 I think you mentioned what was the
dens what is the density in the proposal
for the 21 compared to the 10 on the ex
it it it is actually about double so
it's gone from like 15 dwellings per
hectare to 30 dwellings per
hectare um yeah yeah
yeah yeah BR any points further points
clarification shall we move on to the
debate right to wants to start then okay
thank
you just seeing nobody else coming
forward um I feel happier now that it
that we've we've looked at the
affordable housing mix um
and I think it's it's good that this new
scheme that's come forward offers many
more smaller homes than the larger
properties um because I feel it is in a
in in an appropriate location um based
on the the
plans um there's plenty of Green Space
allocated to each property um and I
can't see a a material planning reason
to refuse so I should be going with the
officer's recommendation
and happy to to have my views considered
as a
proposal she also want to include the um
addition of the foot pass the additional
condition that right and I will just U
give myself leave on this one I'm just
going to go back to point of
clarification Randy which I forgot to
mention did the original that the Paris
can didn't know did the original extent
permission include any Wildlife
mitigation measures uh no it didn't
chair at that time it wouldn't have been
allocated as a wildlife site yeah I just
wanted to clarify that as well thank you
can
f bearing in mind what the parish
council have said about overdevelopment
of this site I would have thought that
the original one which is being
superseded by this one would be far
preferable um with less crowding on on
the site I think I think we touched on
that earlier because it says in the
report that there was the opportunity
was in fact it was not dense enough uh
in the original report and there was the
opportunity to make better use of the
London I think that was referred to by
Anthony on page 36 in the
report sorry I've answer that for you
you have
yet
um right C I'm happy to Second councilor
paris's proposal super duper um yeah I
just have my my temp forth I was
concerned about um the wildlife issue
and obviously with the biodiversity
offset of 100K I think that's certainly
uh helpful especially know we found out
there was any in the original extent
permission again we've got more
affordable houses and again of one and
two bedrooms which I was trying to
carify with the
agent um again making the path more
sustainable and the offsite public open
space contribution
I think that yes we are increasing the
density of this and it might not
necessarily be in keeping with all the
local uh houses but I think the the
benefits why the disadvantages so I
would be supporting this one anyway CH
just to clarify it's I know there's a
contribution for the biodiversity
offsetting but also um it's it's NE rule
so you can actually come up with a a
plan um to offset that in another way as
well as a contribution yeah so yeah the
B yeah thank you for that um so yeah
we've had a vote uh we've had a proposal
and a second to Grant the application
well with the additional condition that
Anthony has mentioned section 106
agreement and the section 106 agreement
all those in
favor three chairman those
against one chairman and abstentions one
chairman committee resolves to Grant
application 18 03223
F thank you
e
we'll move to the next item on the
agenda item number five which is 1803
215 vary L adjacent to holly bush
Cottage holly bush Lane PR M variation
of condition to plan application
17375 f origal description of proposed
development erection of one domestic
dwelling variation to increase two story
size of the drilling and our presting
officer is chair thank you chair thank
you chair the application site is
located with the physical confines of
Prior Martin as indicated before the dot
before on the black dot before
you as indicated on the plan before you
the site is located within a residential
area in close proximity to a number of
dwellings with hollybush cottage iy
Cottage and and woodb carage located to
the South up until recently it was an
area of poorly managed scrub land SL
orhood which was consisted of hro
boundary and a number of mature trees
however the land has been cleared since
the approval of the original
application this application seeks
permission to vary condition to of
planning permission 17 s0
375 full the variations would allow for
the creation of a dwelling on a larger
footprint allowing for an additional
bedroom creating an overall four bedroom
dading the development also includes the
creation of a detached single story gar
and new vehicle access to joining Hol
rate and provision of pedestrian access
adjoining hollyw Lane further amendments
to original approv include minor
alterations to fenestration and en
larged area of hard standard to create
one additional parking
[Applause]
space the plan before you shows the
increasing footprint where the um
proposal is so as you can
see the area es in red is where the main
application is being proposed and the
increase this would be n the footprint
off the
dwelling the r is as matching at 7.1 M
to Ridge and 4.9 M to Eaves the width of
the property remains unchanged at 10.6 M
as you see before the plans for you the
approved plans are on the left and the
proposed plans on the right and you see
how the diff how the um Wing would come
out matching uh the gab enss to the
other matching wing on the left hand
side as well as a join in
here overall the application would are a
total of
301 square m of additional FL floor
space the plans before you show how the
floor space will be allocated so comes
out and from an L-shaped sort of floor
plan it now makes a more Square floor
plan this is a site
area site is located just there that's
holly bush in and the residential
dwellings this view is taken just off
the SES as SES there you're looking down
hollyw Lane there School Lane just
coming off there you can see on the
plant in the right hand
corner holly bush Lane is to the right
uh School Lanes to the left this is a
site
area this is a site area taken in the
car hly bush hly bush in sorry so this
is a site area and the density and the
neighboring dwelling to the
South this photo is just taken off
school Lane School Lanes run down there
in the site area and
overlooking and this is the photo to
save for the property taking just off
Hollywood officer recommendations for
approval um and now new updates thank
you
chair thank you
J first Speaker which is councelor Nick
fford from PR PR
Council
thank you councelor fford you got three
minutes would you like a warn him with
30 I'm fine thanks thank you good
evening I'm Nick fulford chair of prize
master and Parish Council and I'm
speaking in opposition to the proposed
amendment to the land adjacent to
hollybush cottage for from a three bed
to a four-bedroom house this is a small
plot in a conservation area at the
junction of a single track Lane close to
the busy School School the initial
application was for a semi- detached two
and three bed property this was opposed
by par PRI M and Paris Council based on
the overdevelopment of the small site
and the application was
withdrawn a second application was
submitted for a three for a single three
bed house this was not opposed by P PR M
and Parish Council on the basis that its
smaller size was more appropriate to the
small site importantly it also complied
with the requirements are set out in
both our local housing needs survey and
the recently adopted Parish plan that
the parish needs two and three bedroom
houses as opposed to larger four and
five bed houses for which there is
already an overs Supply in fact more
than 50% of properties are already for
bed or larger in the
parish the co strategy policy cs19
housing mix and type indicates the
desire for a general housing mix of 40
to 45% of three bed houses and 15 to 20%
of four bed house four plus bed houses
as just mentioned priz Maron already has
more than 50% four bed houses with only
30% being three bed properties so more
than double the indicated number of four
plus bed houses already exist within the
parish and a 50% under supply of three
bed properties against the core
strategies criteria
I've already mentioned that the Plus in
question is small and the need for
additional parking provision for a four
bed property as opposed to a three bed
propery puts further demands on a small
plot in a tight
location the parish council therefore
opposed the application to change from a
much needed three bed home to a not
needed four bed home on a small plot in
a sensitive area of the village and
therefore ask the committee to listen to
the wishes of the parish as opposed to
those of the
developer thank you thank
you thank you councelor fford any
questions councelor
fford
C has there been engagement between the
parish council and the developer over
the um expansion in the plans no thank
you um could you just um highlight the
parking issue um you mentioned um it's
quite a tight tight plot and what you
you for your your real major concerns
are know quite but could you elucidate
those for me well my my my concerns or
our concerns are that with the extra
hard standing required for an extra
parking Bay um it
basically puts further development
pressure on the
site and reduces I guess the amount of
green space that's in the garden that's
there I just want
I just needed to make sure what what
your final um word was on on the parking
cuz you had mentioned it I just wondered
what you know get a bit more meat on the
bones for that so thank you for bearing
with me on
that questions feel free to go canel for
thank you very
much and our next speaker is Mr
shos
you've got three minutes would you like
a warning Shout with 30 seconds or you
okay with three minutes okay far
away
y all right good evening everyone uh my
name is Matt sharles and I'm a director
of another traditional Country Homes
Limited
I've also represented prize Mar at both
cricket and football and I helped build
the social club up there in the early
80s I apologize for requesting to speak
in on behalf of my company's application
some three weeks
ago uh but uh but being denied to speak
the opportunity was due to Pro protocol
I believe uh I had returned from
Australia the day before early to speak
at the meeting thinking I was going to
speak and as I say was
denied so anyway I'll apologize for any
inconvenience this may have caused cuz I
know somebody from prize Mar has also
turned up to
speak right uh this isn't common
knowledge but it is my intention to
build the house and live there
myself and I would like a four-bedroom
property which I want to build myself
hence the resubmission my company and I
uh have a long association with prize
Marson this in summary is my
grandparents built a house in hollybush
Lane
and they currently they currently reside
in the churchyard in priz Maron uh my
uncle built a house in hollybush Lane
he's renovated a cottage in the village
and he lived there for 20 years and he
sponsored both the football and cricket
teams my father built two houses and
renovated three Cottages within the
village and lived there for 40 years he
also owned the plot of land that om
wished to build
on uh I have built four houses within
the village and carried out numerous
renovations extensions over the years
we're currently working on the clerk of
prize Maron Parish council's house
Believe It or Not uh my fellow director
Rob wils who's with me tonight uh he was
two years old when he moved to prizem
his father was farmed the land around
prize Marson his brother and sister were
both born in priz Marson he has also
represented The Village at football and
Cricket
uh then my company is based within the
neighboring Parish of
napton we employed Tradesmen from the
parishes of priz maren as well as napton
Stockton southam harbory long and Bishop
sington we pride ourselves in our
reputation for quality of build and also
leaing with local residents doing all we
can to Min as any disruption we are very
disappointed uh we are very uh
approachable which is why I'm
disappointed that Pros Mar and po counil
have forly objected to to uh our
proposal without sort of contacting us
to discuss first uh to conclude this I
would ask you to support the application
so that I can move into a house that I
want to build myself uh I will then
become a resident priz Marson and I may
wish to involve myself within the
community either way of building or uh
sponsoring local teams as we do with
napton sports and Stockton
Sports thank you thank you that was spot
on that right
any questions for the agent C
Don good evening thank you for outlining
your links with the um the village can I
check how do you respond to the parish
council's concern about lack of garden
space and parking
issues yeah it's funny to say about the
parking because I've just looked at
previous applications and we have to
provide three parking spaces for a
four-bedroomed house and we have to
enter the site and leave the site in a
forward
gear but looking at previous
applications you had up here at Lor they
have tandem parking and they have to
reverse onto the
highway is that double standards
sorry so again back to my question how
do you respond to their concerns about
lack of garden space and the um parking
issue with this particular application
not the ones we've listened to before
firstly I'm not a gardener so I don't
wish to do a lot of
gardening uh
so it doesn't bother me as I want to
live there you see
and you've mentioned you're building the
house for yourself how long do you plan
on staying there is it a
longterm well okay who knows yeah okay
we'll move on that one that's I can see
where you're coming from that question
but it's not quite a plation
um yeah I think there was obviously
concern from the parish council M about
um about the type of
property being in keeping with the rest
of the The Village being 50 % of four
bedroom houses
um sorry the
brain's I'll read you at this I've just
completely lost my train of thought so
I'll come
back the materials that you're the house
is not built at the moment do I
understand that no so the materials that
you're going to be building is that
local stone or it is and that is that
the what stone is it haunton or it's
haunton Stone so it's going to be within
keeping of the rest of the village most
certainly and the the rear extens rear
extension at the back will be done in uh
White World English brick so it looks
like it's an extension to an Old Stone
property and is what sort of roofing
material
slate more questions gone
so I'll leave it now canc
s yes chairman has it in my mind as the
everyone have heard me speaking about
parking on a previous
application um I've got the consultation
document where the consultation expired
on the 15th here and indeed if this is
adopted it has a fair amount of weight
at the moment and it replaces a previous
document um that was adopted um then you
will need to provide three car parking
spaces for a four-bedroom house is that
going to be possible on this site no we
already
have sorry that's one of the requests of
the warshire County
Council so I think you just you
confirmed that there are yeah just to
confirm to councel Sate his question
that you you have provided or you will
provide to we've
increased when we
resubmitted we not don't want to live
there we re submitted the
application with the two parking spaces
that were
granted and then we were asked to
provide another parking space because it
was a four bedroom property so we have
done you happy can Saint does that
answer your question question no just
need to clarify that I think you're
you're free to go well thank you thank
you and we're going on to uh points of
clarification
thank you yes I just wonder whe I can
have
some clarification because um whether
this just applies to an existing
dwelling rather than a a a dwelling
that's got planning application as
extension um Conservation Area um unless
I'm blind I couldn't see a specific
report from the conservation officer on
this but maybe it's not required um but
my other question was I was under the
impression that you couldn't um extend
to the rear by more than 4 MERS or by
two stories on a on a on a building in a
conservation area but perhaps that's one
of existing built form um so perhaps if
I could just have a little bit of
clarification on
that firstly by count officers
procedures um because it's not listed it
goes down to officer discretion on the
conservation area so the impact
assessment will be done by the officer
um they may very very well take
consultation like informal talks with
the conservation officer but you don't
consult with the conservation officer
itself in regards to extensions I think
what you're referring to is permitted
development rights under that sort of
element you could do certain extensions
to the riter but it's PD you wouldn't
need the PLO plan and permission in this
case obviously it's well above permited
development rights and therefore they
apply for plan and permission then the
assessment comes in on a whole plan and
application on impact on character
overlooking the meeting is so
forth can you give me a rough percentage
wise the increase on the original
place is 30 square m if you go to uh the
best way to do it is there's a good set
SE under the page
52 of your committee report where it
talks about the depth and you can see
the dimensions in depth there in the
report where it analyzes property to be
8.5 M deep which reare elevation squared
of um second paragraph
yeah any other points
clarification think we've exhausted that
quite a well should we move on to the
devate now who would like to start on
this counc
F I'm happy to support the officer's
recommendation to approve I can see it's
very much in keeping because I know the
village it's very much in keeping using
H and stone um and I see no reason to
refusing
it g car if you could okay could I just
um one point one Omission um that we
real ized on the
recommendation um in accordance with the
protocol in relation to stone stone
built stone built um proposals there's a
requirement for a sample panel as well
um now that was on the
original planning per planning
permission um it's not showing up on
your list so I'd like to insert that
before you go to a recommendation stage
sample panel to be built um slub slub
level so not a pre commencement
condition can I second that one on the
grounds that we I instigated it for
tyser so I don't see why I shouldn't
have instigate it
locally uh anybody else want to comment
C thank you chair I well Wade my size
sevens in um I'm happy to Second this
application I can't really see um I
understand the parish is objection
because they're Keen to have a
three-bedroom but in terms of its design
and layout um the main attraction of
this Cottage is from the front and
you're not making it look bulky it comes
back into its depth um I think it's um
appreciate it's not a consideration but
a self
self-build um proposition is always to
be encouraged um and therefore I have
pleasure in seconding the proposal to to
Grant
application and accept the conditions
propos right we've had a proposal and
the second um all those in favor
of
agreement unanimous
chair committee resoles to Grant
application 18
03215 SL thank you very
much
sorry I've not got my microphone on I
did nobody notice that and first for
extension over existing I'll start again
sorry we'll move on to the final
application on the agenda 18/3 616 ful B
Barn Front Street elington single story
rare extension and first floor extension
over existing insertion of conservation
roof light reshaping of existing Doma
Windows removal of Chimney and Doma on
the rear elevation installation of
replacement windows and boold doorer
demolition of existing single story
extension and aring is our Pres sent an
officer thank
you thank you chair the application site
lies to the north of ilmington Village
as identified by the black dot on this
Slide the settlement the site Falls
within the cell's area of outstanding
natural beauty and adjacent to the
cotwell F special landscape area
ilmington has a neighborhood development
plan which is currently at
pre-submission consultation
stage this slide identifies the
application site outlined in red just
shown here to the North and South lie
two gray two listed buildings the pink
line shows the extent of the
conservation area the a is behind this
line over here and The cotwell Fringe
special landscape area is adjacent to
the sites are across the road in this
area on the right hand side of the slide
the site line is adjacent to Front
Street and has an existing access just
down to the side which goes down to the
rear of the
property plan permission is sought for
the reting a single story rear extension
a first floor side extension and rear
extension new roof lights the removal of
an existing chimney and alterations to
the windows including new dormal windows
the site is outlined in red and this
shows an aerial image from above you can
see the application property here the
neighbors to the north and to the South
and Open Fields
opposite this slide shows the proposed
floor plans for the dwelling The Works
include a rear single story flat roof
extension which is this section here
which will serve a breakfast kitchen
area there are two roof lights proposed
above which you can see on the roof plan
here and here there's lean to single
story extension in this area here which
you can see Pitch roof on this side and
over the existing projection to the rear
there is a first floor Edition there are
also changes within the roof space and a
new roof light is being proposed just in
this area
here this slide shows proposed
elevations of the property I would
advise all the windows are changing on
the property as well to the rear you can
see the pitch roof element which
projects the rear the changes to the
window so are bfold doors leading onto
the garden from the flat roof extension
pitch roof extension is just shown here
to the right hand side and the pitch
roof dor is are shown here here and here
this is a chimney to be removed there's
a further dormal window which you can
see on this south facing
elevation this slide shows a section of
the property you can see there's a
change in ground level going to the rear
of the site and from the neighboring
property this is the existing side
elevation facing onto the neighboring
property with a projection here you can
see the two chimneys above and below the
new pitch roof element over the first
floor which is this section
here a number of photographs taken from
within the area this is hob days which
is a grade two building and then the
application property here this
photograph's taken from Front Street you
can see the open space opposite the site
this photograph is taken back up looking
towards the application site and you see
on the right hand side the neighboring
properties with hobday's branches shown
here on the right hand side this image
on the bottom left is panning round and
you can see the application property
approximately here just to give an idea
of the context of the site and then this
final photograph on the bottom right is
looking away from the application site
to the north we can see other
neighboring properties if you just look
at the plan to the South it's just
looking in this area over
here this Photograph shows the
application site taken from the road you
can see the vehicle access to the left
hand side of the image this is the
neighboring property which is listed to
the right hand side of the image
this Photograph shows a rear property
and you can see the access to the right
hand side as the site slopes down into
the site and you've got the existing
flat roof dormal windows on the rear
elevation and the projection just there
there's existing access here and
parking this slide shows the rear
elevation because of the the location of
the swimming pool and the the Hedge R is
already on the site it just pans around
so this is a rear single story monop
pitch projection existing flat roof
dormal windows as you pan around to the
right hand side this is the chimney to
be removed moving across and then
looking across and there's hob days
which is a grade to listed building on
the right of this
image this slide shows a photograph
looking from Front Street up towards the
application site this is the area where
the first floor audition is proposed and
you can see the gap between the site and
the road as it slopes in this norly
direction this is hob days which is a
gray two listed
building and this photograph was taken
from hobday's Barnes Garden which is the
adjacent property to the north just here
looking back at the application site
there is a change in ground level which
is visible in this image you can see
that the application site is on a higher
level this is the area where the
extension is
proposed this final image was taken from
the access of hobday's barn looking back
towards the application site you can see
the mono pitch extension it's already on
the property here the other Lake grade
two listed building in a distance and
the relationship with the neighboring
property there are a number of updates
which have been circulated on the update
sheet including two new conditions which
replace the existing materials condition
in the report the recommendation is a
grant planning permission subject to the
conditions and notes outlined on page 86
and in the update sheet thank
you
and going a bit blank in front of
us thank you uh we'll move on to our
first Speaker which is Nikki
Schlatter hopefully I've pronounced that
oh good thank you I didn't
uh and we've got who are you are
you
Jan
Mars so um yeah there was a list of
residents who might have come up to to
answer questions
Areo there was a on the on the sheet
there's a list of um residents who who
could potentially come from for to
answer
questions
so are
you Jan shwood and if we got Alan and
Jean
hustle um they are registered so they
can answer questions but um if they want
to come forward and
sit just do with two for now chair and
then are you happy happy as we are yes
okay fine I just making sure everybody's
as long as we're all happy we're all
happy right far away we've got 3 minutes
and we'll give you a warning with about
30 seconds if that's okay thank
you I live in hob Barn directly
Northeast of and bordering B Barn I
along with my neighbors and the parish
council oppose the application for the
following reasons firstly with all due
respect to the case officer he has
recommended approval without viewing the
proposed extension from my garden or
receiving any advice from the
conservation team having already DEC
decided I submit he could not he could
not have viewed the proposed extension
with an open mind when he viewed it from
my garden for the first time
yesterday I suggest that this has
tainted his assessment and his decision
could be
challenged my my house is a grade two
listed building in a conservation area
and in an a NB and the proposed
extension would cause harm to its
setting I believe the case officer can
give a view on this but he is not a
conservation expert due to the
sensitivity of my property status its
orientation location and ground level I
believe it would be prudent for the
committee to defer its decision so that
a proper and independent assessment of
the proposed extension impact can be
carried out with a site visit by a
conservation officer and the committee
members on this slide slide one please
you'll see that my property sits around
1.8 m lower than the already dominant
Bay Tree Barn with the height to the
proposed extension it would be even more
overbearing next slide please The
Proposal calls for a new roof length of
over 10 m and its height from my ground
level would be nearly 10 m as well the
applicant suggests that because my house
has has had permission for a single
Story 3 m by 3 M Glass Conservatory that
this is somehow comparable to the extens
to the erection of an imposing
stone-built Second Story extension this
is both misleading and
disingenuous the ground level of my
garden and Conservatory is 1 M below
street level and does not impact the
street scene secondly the house already
cast a significant Shadow over the
length of my back Garden next slide
please this photo was taken at 1:30 p.m.
in late February and that is without the
extension should that extension be built
my amenity will be severely affected 30
seconds finally the proposed extension
would cause harm to the street scene
next slide please this photo was taken
from Front Street looking at the
property and just shows just how visible
and dominant it already is for these
reasons I request you defer your
decision until an independent and proper
assessment can be carried out on the
impact of a grade two listed building in
a conservation area and a thank
you have we any
questions so I've got one
um if I can find the right paper sorry
I've had a we've had a lot of two and
and Throne
today
um what consultation again with
yourselves and the par par Council have
have you been involved in the process
that's yeah yes I attended a parish
council meeting and and presented at the
meeting uh and obviously they object but
they weren't able to send anybody today
no unfortunately they couldn't yeah okay
thank you any further
questions right thank you very much for
your clear presentation thank
you
now move on to points of clarification
you got the agent
so sure my legal officer was awaken on
the
ball which I am which he was thank you
for that you've got three minutes could
I have a sort of 30 second yeah warning
thank you okay so uh good evening I am
here on behalf of my client to speak in
support of this householder application
for extensions to bayry Barn I thank
officers for their constructive feedback
and assistance to date and fully endorse
their positive
recommendation the scheme is for a first
floor extension a single story rear
extension and the demolition of the
existing rear extension it uses
materials that match bery barn and it is
cited to the rear and side elevations of
the existing it will not cause harm to
the character or appearance of the
street scene of the Conservation Area
and this has been supported by the
conservation officer's comments on the
update sheet objections have been raised
on concerns of overshadowing and
overbearing on the gray two listed
hobday barn and overlooking into
neighboring properties as the proposed
elevation drawings demonstrate the first
floor addition is not overly dominant
and will have little added impact on the
setting of hobes barn than at present
the first floor extension is actually
set slightly lower than the existing
Power Pit roof and its pitch means that
will not result in any further loss of
light in light of this and the distance
from hobday's Barn The Proposal will not
have a significantly overbearing impact
on the listed Barn to the detriment of
its setting to ensure no loss of privacy
for Neighbors no windows are located on
the elevation facing the nearest
property only one first floor window on
the rear elevation is proposed which
does not directly face any dwellings the
window does not breach the 45 degree
line to any habital room windows at
heren Brook lodge or hobday's Barn this
plan illustrates areas of potential
overlooking from the
extension the closest parts of the
neighboring dwellings are both garages
and the only windows are two
conservation roof lights at hering Brook
that do not allow
overlooking the external private imunity
of hering Brook is to the north of the
property as you can see in green and
cannot be overlooked due to TPO trees on
the boundary in between and the
two-story Lodge itself which obscures
views to its Garden the plan also shows
in red two small areas of land where
there is potential for overlooking the
area of land at hob Barn is gravel
driveway and at heren Brook it is a
sliver of land behind the garage as you
can see red hatches on there neither of
which are suitable for use as private
imunity space due to their location and
small size it should be noted that the
parish council's objection on
overlooking grounds related solely to
the Juliet Balcony which has since been
removed from the plans to summarize as
per policy cs20 the extension will not
unaccept unacceptably detract from the
amenities of the neighboring properties
and will not adverse impact the setting
of the listed hob Barn through loss of
light or privacy dominance overlooking
or
overshadowing we hope that this is a
straightforward decision to approve the
scheme in line with the officer's
recommendation and trust that members
will agree I am happy to answer any
questions you may have thank
you shall I start um you mentioned about
the Julia balcony which has been removed
uh from the parish council but on the
front page page 77
um Paris Council objection received on
the grounds of impact of
overshadowing overshadowing on hob day's
Barn the pitch roof will dominate hob
day's barn and the pitch roof will
adversely affect the setting of listed
building hob day bar so I thought it was
just more than the Juliet Balcony uh the
point four of their objection was
specifically to the Juliet balcony and
it's been removed since they even said
on the thing that they would remove that
part of their objection if the Juliet
Balcony was removed
um agreed that that there were their
objections but the conservation officer
has responded since that point which is
on the up sheet which gives a bit more
information thank you C to did you
indicate
now really but I am concerned about and
probably it's really something for the
planning officer is that if we go back
to the side
elevation no the
photographs
that
one how much above that wall is the new
extension going to be or is that 3 m so
you're taking it up an extra 3 m yes
because we're setting the parit roof is
at an angle but we're actually setting
the extension slightly lower so instead
of it being wall then roof it's just the
roof so you're saying the pitch of the
roof is going to be 3 m High yes but
it's going that direction not directly
up if that makes sense so it's going to
have the same slope as it you've got
there
now sorry the roof is sloping down
towards yes but it's going to be dual
pitch rather than the set the first so
you are going to have a pitch roof yes
yes it's a pitch roof yeah so is the 3 m
as the top of the pitch I think it
probably be easier to show you on the
ele the side elevation um it's the next
slide
down
so that's how that's how high it's going
but it is it starts slightly lower than
the existing cuz what I'm concerned
about is the loss of sunlight in the
garden to the the barn so are you going
to be allowing more sunlight or you
going to be taking more sunlight
away well considering the shadow as it
is now I don't think this bit would
actually add to it because of the angle
of the pitch it's not a direct wall
against it it's pitch of the sunlight
will come over and
down if that makes
sense thank you for that the officer as
well any further questions to the agent
thank you Natasha and apologies for
missing originally sorry about that
thank you very
much so we will be going on to points of
clarification can
par thank you I wonder whether the
planning team can
advise um why the case officer didn't
visit the neighboring property until 24
hours prior to the planning EAS
committee so the assessment was carried
out from the site and the street scene
and Round by the access and some of the
photographs were taken as part of that
assessment um yes we were went out to
take some further photographs and
members for the committee presentation
so that's why the extra photographs are
quite
recent
sorry can I just come back to that so
but the case officer did did was not in
a position to look at the plans from the
neighboring Garden until 24 hours ago is
that
correct it's my understanding the full
assessment was carried out and it was
taken into account the neighbor's
property which is addressed in the
report um as you can get down to the
access and this Viewpoint is available
as well and from the road as part part
of the
assessment so C parry's taking your
question C
pH I'm surprised that the conservation
officer um hasn't really taken much
interest in this development because it
is very close to two grade listed
buildings and I would have thought
judging from
the um use of the building W the windows
and other matters they're not really in
keeping with the sort of conservation
type design if we got a question there
John please why hasn't the conservation
officers had more input thank you we
don't normally consult with conservation
officers if it's not a listed building
um we might have informal discussions in
this case we've asked for some extra
comments which are on the update sheets
part of the the assessment just to add
to to the assessment but it is normally
carried out by case officers when
there's something in the Conservation
Area area and we don't formally consult
conservation team in those
circumstances just just for
clarification this isn't a listed
building so that that would be the that
would be the trigger for for a
consultation um where it's a non-listed
building within the conservation area
that that will generally be left to the
to the case officer to do the assessment
with perhaps some informal comments
where that's appropriate from the
conservation officer but they wouldn't a
formal
consultation okay so don um just going
back to the question that was asked of
the agent regarding the loss of sunlight
um can you throw any more clarification
on that for us will there be a loss of
sunlight with the increase in roof
height basically additional Shadow thank
you that's so the offic report goes into
detail about an assessment um we take
into account I just bring up the block
plan me two seconds the separation
distances as well um let me just find
the so I just pop this on the
screen this is the black PL you can see
this hob Barn which is neighboring
property at the lower level the road
slopes down this way and it slopes in
this direction um as part of the
assessment there about 16 M from the
rear elevation of hob Barn to the edge
of the site the pitch roof is on the
rear elevation here but it is a pitch
roof so the highest part of the the
element is about I think it's 2.8 MERS
away from
the boundary so that's a consideration
as well so we would have considered all
of the elements as part of the
assessment and then the impact looking
at what the relationship at the moment
and then what any greater relationship
is and that takes into account the
orientation of the property the distance
the level change and that's all
outlining the officer report as part of
the
assessment just a very quick comment is
that we rather we need question is the
the photograph was taken was in Winter
surely if it was a photograph taken in
summer when the sun is higher it would
be a
different
Shadow I think we are where we are when
the advocation comes in and you know
unfortunately lacation came in in in the
middle of winter rather than the middle
of summer so I know it's a comment but I
think we can't allow
that
can party is that a question or
debate debate yeah thank you
um I would feel more comfortable to have
a site visit we have no comment from the
Ward member I appreciate the ward member
has uh not been well recently I'd
therefore like to put forward a proposal
for a deferral and a site visit by
members of the planning East team to be
able to assess the situation I think
it's it's always the same with it the
the the the small smaller applications
that come before us are often far more
difficult to really assess and I feel on
this occasion particularly in um
ilmington which is uh um where it's like
any other cotwell Village I think it's
important that we we give due
consideration to the issues that have
been raised we also have an objection
from the parish council um and on the
basis that the having heard this evening
that the case officer went back and is
the first time has actually stood in the
neighbor's property I think a deferral
would be appropriate um for the next
meeting having had a site visit
beforehand C I don't know um I'd like to
Echo councilor paris's request for a
site visit I think although it's not a
listed building it is sandwich between
and it would be important for us to
actually um do a site visit for that and
also I am concerned regarding the fact
that it was only 24 hours before the
meeting that the the case officer
managed to to see it from the the
neighboring perspective so I really Echo
what council Paris requested visit and
defer until then
seconding that's the word we were
looking seconding that's the one thank
you very much um we've had a proposal on
the second to defer the application uh
for a site visit I'll go along with the
two
ladies so we'll go to the vote on the
decision uh the request or proposal from
Council Pary to defer the application
for a solid
visit uh for the reasons given do that
vote thank
you was defer the application for a site
visit thank
you and there's no urgent business so I
declare tonight's
me
closed